six exec today but we will definitely
be doing two
minimum
all right and i'll get you those
as you know representative um
nunez
has left our our fair committee and
representative love from fish and game
who i don't see here yet will be joining
us as a permanent member of the labor
committee
mental representative pimento is filling
in for ben burundi today so welcome to
the labor committee we're going to start
thank you representative smith
representative toomey would you lead us
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
liberty and stands for all
thank you any questions of the chair
oh yes i'm sorry
infantine
yes here
seaworth here
avaloni
callum
mackie myself
love
warden
proud
schmidt
toomey
bouchard
adjutant
mandeville
do we have any sponsor
representative
i'm sorry i don't have i apologize i
didn't have any pink cards so i didn't
all right when you're done
please uh submit one when you're done
thank you mr chair and
uh members of the committee for hearing
my testimony today i'm here to talk
about my bill hb1124
to mandate e-verify
in this state
the issue of illegal immigration
is one that is top on the minds of my
constituents
and people all across my district
and really this entire state have asked
what can we do
to try to alleviate some of the concerns
and problems from illegal immigration
last year 1.9 million illegal immigrants
entered
through the southern border
so we have an unprecedented rise in
illegal immigrants we have an
unprecedented rise in the past year of
drug overdoses we see a rise of crime
and just general economic issues and so
how to solve illegal immigration is one
of the issues that's top on my
constituents minds
now
uh
issues or solutions like uh providing
more border security or building a wall
or empowering ice one those are all
things we can't do in the state of new
hampshire but two
those are all policy solutions that are
deeply divided if you look at the poll
numbers many don't support those in our
country and in our state
but what is the one solution to legal
immigration
that is efficient and widely popular
with republicans independents and even
democrats depending on the poll you look
at mandatory e-verify a majority of
businesses already implement e-verify
in this state and across the country
it's relatively easy to conduct it's a
common sense solution to deal with the
issue of illegal immigration
all this bill does is mandate e-verify
which is just a quick check to see if
someone that a business is hiring is in
fact a legal immigrant
this does not
go after illegal immigrants this does
not deport illegal immigrants all this
does is make sure businesses in new
hampshire that are hiring folks are
following the law and hiring legal
immigrants so this is a relatively
straightforward bill
we have many regulations
in this state
this is not a very intrusive one but
this is an important one
at this time i'm happy to take
any questions and actually i'll just add
to be very clear the people of new
hampshire
do not want illegal immigration in this
state and this is a common sense
solution to crack down on illegal
immigration
and i'm happy to take any questions at
this
time thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um
where would the
information go to after
a certain person would apply for a job
and is verified
would it be purged or
well thank you representative for the
question
um
so this bill
does not outline
what happens
to an individual that would be an
one
that's not what this bill is about this
bill is not a punitive measure to go
after legal immigrations after legal
immigrants all it does
is it mandates and puts the liability on
the business so they are not hiring
illegal immigrants plus in a way it
reduces their liability because if
they're conducting this this background
check essentially they know that they're
not hiring illegal immigrants
and so
all it does
is if they pass or excuse me if they
don't pass that check because they are
an illegal immigrant they're no longer
hired it doesn't mean necessarily that
they're being deported but what you
would expect over time is if illegal
immigrants are not able to pass this
check they can't get a job they would
likely move to other states over time
because they're going to go to places
where it's easier for them to get a job
so
you can you can um i hope that i'm
answering your question in the sense
that this bill doesn't outline that all
it does is put the emphasis on the
employer to make sure the person they're
hiring is legal or not does that answer
your question sir
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just out of curiosity
and pardon me for not knowing the
question but is this a big problem in
representative thank you for the
question
not only from just constituents but also
businesses in my district the issue of
illegal immigration is one that's top on
the minds
of
of my constituents if you look at polls
it's one of the top three issues in the
country so it absolutely is a big issue
and as i outlined because of just the
general economy rising crime rise in
overdoses people are very concerned
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question i
wanted to follow up on my on a question
of my colleague mr susie and is there
anything currently preventing an
employer from using the irreversify
well thank you for the question
representative uh there is not
and a majority of businesses in this
country already use e-verify
and there's many businesses in new
hampshire especially those that operate
in multiple states
in some states which require e-verify
that they already use it in new
hampshire so this bill just mandates it
for every business but there's
absolutely nothing that require that
prevents excuse me a business from using
e-verify in this state
follow-up
uh so in a sense while this the
intention may be good you are in fact
yeah it's pretty straightforward this is
an additional layer of regulation and
there's some folks
um
typically from the more conservative
side that might be against this bill for
that reason
i would just say that we have a
regulatory burden in this country that's
1.75 trillion dollars we have
lots of regulations for the health or
safety of a variety of different things
why can't we have a widely popular not
very intrusive efficient regulation to
deal with one of the biggest issues
illegal immigration
so that would be my
sort of argument that sure this is a
small additional regulation but we have
lots of regulations why would we not
have a regulation that's not that
a lot of questions a lot of hands i see
everybody let me go in order here
representative
warden
and thanks for your testimony
is there a cost to employers to use the
so i think the answer is there's a cost
to everything
in the sense that it's an additional
layer of regulation
right the regulatory burden that 1.75
trillion dollars isn't necessarily it
costs our businesses 1.75 trillion
dollars but it's a time thing someone's
gonna have to
be on staff to submit
everything right to deal with that it's
additional paperwork
so there is a small layer of regulatory
cluster that is going to impact
businesses
just like every other regulation that we
put on businesses
follow-up
but by the current statute the employers
are already required to obtain
documentation showing
the employee's eligibility ability to
work in the u.s correct
that's correct but e-verify
is a
common sense way
to to deal with illegal immigration it's
a streamlined process that most
businesses already use and we're one of
the few states that does not have
mandatory e-verify so this is
essentially bringing new hampshire's
regulatory code up with this issue up
with many other states bringing it to
par does that make sense does that
um i want to say that's correct
a mental
no what is this sorry how do you
okay
pimentel pimento it's
depends
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions
uh i noticed in your opening remarks
that you
uh gave a figure of i think 1.3 million
illegal immigrants coming across the
southern border
and kind of a follow-up on a question
asked earlier
do you know how many
illegal immigrants there are in new
hampshire
so representative that was 1.9 million
illegal immigrants that entered the
country um from the southern border last
year and that's an estimate of course
um from from border patrol so we don't
truly know the exact number um and how
many of those
remain in the united states
excuse me
it's impossible to know with absolute
certainty but as you might know about 50
percent of illegal immigrants come from
folks that are overstaying their visa
so i would imagine that new hampshire
there's nothing that i'm aware of that
would
make us out of whack with that national
trend
so i don't know the exact number of
illegal immigrants but i think most
people think the right number should be
zero in this state that's why i hear
from my constituents they want us to
sullivan
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
could you explain exactly how e-verify
works and especially what the error rate
is
um is for example is my name in the
e-verify system to verify that
i'm i'm here
properly and able to be employed i'm
concerned about someone who
is
eligible to be employed might get
flagged by the e-verify system for some
reason so please explain how it works
well representative sullivan thanks for
the question uh e-verify works very
simply the same way any other background
check would work which is conducted
i'm a landlord for example so when we
screen tenants we do a background check
and any background check can have an
error rate that's just that's the way it
works it doesn't mean that we shouldn't
conduct a background check or we
shouldn't conduct e-verify so of course
you're going to have false positives and
negatives that are you know wrong as
well that just comes along with with any
background check system so it's there
really isn't that much to it um it's as
simple as an answer i can give to you
sir
up
but you didn't really tell me how it
works
i just said it's like any other
background check but
is it a list of
names of illegal immigrants is a list of
names of uh citizens as well as uh legal
uh immigrants how does it work yeah so
let me try to be more specific
representative so
all any verified check is doing is
running to see if someone's social
security number is accurate see if they
are a legal citizen in the united states
so they can check you have so for
example if i was going through an
e-verify check they'd say okay this is
my social security number yes he is a
legal citizen of the united states he's
good to go we're able to hire him that's
it
and then to me and i'll keep going after
that
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um i was just curious
is this a private company that
verify or is it a government company who
well thank you uh representative for
your question
um
so an e-verify check you you're doing a
couple of things so who's actually
running the check
but then so like processing it but then
you have to check and see if someone is
a legal citizen so you're using that
social security number and ultimately
the government has that information
right so
you you have to do both layers there
where you have to process it but then
you need the correct information so i
hope that answers your question
that it would it'd probably be a private
public partnership on that check there
thank you mr chairman
um
thank you for taking another question
from me
um
i i i'm guessing that this
is not going to be that easy to
implement
in that
maybe you can
tell me how this would work but
i get the feeling just from what it is
here
just like when we go to vote
every new employee is going to have to
have
an e-verify no matter what
and
that
being said how do we make sure
that every employer
actually e-verifies
every
prospective employee
what is what is the check and balance
here
so representative i just want to get
crystal clear on what you're asking the
question is how do we make sure
employers are in fact using e-verify for
yes
well thank you for the question
representative
i i guess it's like anything else you
know i'm i'm a little perplexed
by the question
you're asking how do we like if you have
a law which we have in many different
instances
how do we make sure that every school is
using a background check when we have
people that are working with children
right of course we would want
a teacher to have a background check
before they're working with little kids
how do we mandate that the school
requires the background check and that
they actually use it
i i'm not it's not any different than
that so i i'm perplexed as to
why that is a concern the same way that
we have ma mandates on lots of other
things
and representative if you want to ask a
follow-up
go right ahead
thank you well because i'm just
i just i said that because i i'm i just
want to make sure that i'm answering the
question for the members of the
committee but i'm just i'm going to take
a time out here
represent would you like to take your
seat
representative mitchell do you have a
follow-up question
uh
yes mr chairman uh
my question is basically um a matter of
fairness
uh
i
i wonder whether or not
people are only going to use e-verify on
um
their prospective employees who have an
accent for instance
and not every single employee
that
comes and applies for the job that is
your question to the presenter
yes it is all right thank you
well thank you representative for the
question uh
same as as i was saying if you were
conducting a background check on
teachers working with kids regardless of
someone's race gender age you have to
conduct the e-verify check it's very
important that's why that's why it
should be mandated because right now
when we don't have mandated e-verify
you're probably dealing with a situation
where it's more likely that an employer
might selectively run an e-verify check
this law would bring it up to par so all
all people that are being hired are
subject to that e-verify check which
isn't that intrusive but it's done
fairly to everyone
i see only one more here
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for presenting um
as we know
rsa 275a has a penalty
uh section of 2500 per day for
violations
um
so my concern about
this um uh amendment to 275
a4a
and the use of and
between
verifying through e-verify and obtaining
documentation
suggests that for example if someone
came in with what appeared to be
legitimate
um
documentation such as a birth
certificate or a social security card
and the employer did not
um
proceed with the e-verify system they
could be subjected to
uh the penalties under 275 a by virtue
of having failed to do that if the
documentation was
not
uh legitimate not accurate
does does that possibility cause you any
concern or would you consider the idea
of making them in the disjunctive rather
well representative can you clarify the
question from me um
what you're saying just
you're saying if there's false
documentation
meaning what exactly
no i'm going to interject here because
we got to get this thing moving you have
and
on line five
so you want to e-verify and all this
other documentation
in our law you have a 2500 fine
for violation plus a hundred dollars per
person per day
the question i believe is
go ahead now i answer your question
thank you
would that create
liabilities for potential liabilities
for companies that did due diligence but
not enough because they didn't pursue
both avenues and um
were therefore subject to penalty
for uh having failed to do one one part
of the other of those
well thank you for the question uh
representative um
you know i appreciate the concern and i
do think that this bill is a step in the
right direction because
right now if we have businesses that are
not conducting an e-verify check
but they do hire an illegal immigrant
and very well could be by accident not
deliberately
they are potentially liable because of
that so this is a way
for employees to say great i'm checking
the box i'm not hiring a legal immigrant
this is a step in the right direction
but i appreciate the concern
representative
i have one question
can you please tell me how many states
in the union you uh have mandatory
e-filing requirements
it's a majority of states i don't have
the exact number off the top of my head
mr representative avaloni
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking the question
um
would a business be mandated to
verify employment even after obtaining
documentation because to me it seems
that it's out of order as it's written
they should
no employer shall employ any employee
without obtaining documentation and
verifying employment
because you can't verify you use the
e-verify system without obtaining the
documentation
seems a little bit out of order to me
so representative every business has to
conduct the e-verify check for employees
that they're hiring that's what the bill
does does that answer your question
representative
continuing your other questions thank
you very much representative baxter i
want the community to know that lexi
rojas is here from the hampshire doll
i'm gonna have her um come up last after
people could testify and then follow
with any questions that the committee
has with her
maggie forwardy
thank you
it's counter intuitive
good morning my name is maggie fogerty
i'm with the american friends service
committee a quaker
organization working on issues of
immigrant justice and other forms of
human rights around the world
and i'm speaking on behalf of the new
hampshire immigrant rights network which
is a statewide coalition of
organizations
individuals faith leaders attorneys who
are working together for
humane immigration policy certainly at
the federal level where immigration
policy is set but also as uh
immigration-related issues impact our
state and even municipal
uh activities and we're here to urge you
to oppose hb
1124.
uh this bill as you understand would
unnecessarily require every single
employer in new hampshire no matter the
size of the business to use the federal
e-verify system
i'm glad that the representative from
the department of labor is here to
answer some of the specific questions
that you've raised already i don't i'm
not an employment law expert or anything
like that simply an immigration
advocate
the e-verify program was enacted in 1996
with the purpose of curbing the
employment of persons who aren't
eligible or authorized to work in the
united states
it's operated by the u.s citizenship and
immigration services
uscis which cross-checks the information
submitted by an employer with their own
database of
work authorization
currently 22 states not a majority 22
states have adopted mandatory e-verify
in the united states you'll see the list
of those states in the footnote of our
testimony which i will submit
however despite even
with 22 states adopting this the rate of
participation by businesses even in
those states is very low
in 2018 the department of homeland
security had enrolled 821
771 employers because you you create an
account you log in
in e-verify amounting to
13.5
of all employers in the united states so
this means that 86.5 percent of u.s
employers refuse to use e-verify in
2018.
although the error rates have improved
over the years the e-verify program has
caused harm to many people who are
authorized to work in the united states
but because of maybe hyphenated names
complex names names that are frequently
misspelled
they are deemed to be ineligible by
their employer with an obvious
harm to the employer actively seeking
employees never more
intensely than now but certainly even
more acutely to the family relying on
that income for their basic well-being
and again that would be for harm done to
authorized workers
in 2018 approximately 70 000 people
received erroneous eligibility
determinations and over the life of the
program since 1996 nearly three-quarters
of a million legal workers have been
harmed
the time to challenge an initial
determination of ineligibility
is very short it's only eight business
days and some applicants are neither
informed nor given an opportunity to
we believe that the e-verify program is
not necessary because of the broad and
heavily enforced requirement that all
employers submit the i-9 documentations
as well so this would be an unnecessary
overlay
we think that
creating a more coherent
immigration system in the united states
where there are clear pathways and
adequate resources to process people's
visa applications immigration benefit
applications
is much more worthy of our energy than
overlaying this
also employers frequently misunderstand
their obligations with regard to this
program and that increases their
liability for for penalties so they
could as has been mentioned
only use e-verify for those they
perceive to be non-citizens and that
certainly invites a claim of racial
profiling
they can they often use it to pre-screen
potential employees which is not an
authorized use and then the applicant
never knows that they've been
denied work for a mistake
and they are also in error when they
fail to notify the employee when there's
been a negative determination
and there aren't any due process
protections written into the federally
verified law for an employee who is
harmed
so for a state that understands itself
to be business friendly we don't see
this as adding anything to the equation
all employers can use e-verify if they
so choose
so the letter i'll submit to you today
is signed by 50 people who care about
this issue you'll see a diverse range of
towns and of organizational associations
i'm happy to
take any questions you may have or to
just leave room for my colleagues to
speak representative proud
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned that
there was a limited time window to
challenge a negative determination does
the burden of challenging the negative
determination fall on the business or on
the individual
it would be the individual who
could
you know correct
what the what they perceive the error to
be or to ask that the documentation be
resubmitted in a difference with a
um
so they would have to work in
conjunction with the business so both
would be involved because the business
would have to resubmit with a different
name so it would be a burden on both of
them
it would if
yes but the all of the the i mean the
primary kind of consequence of that
erroneous determination is on the worker
then who wouldn't be
able to either start that job or
very much
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question might an umlaut in
your name
make it difficult to correctly identify
your status yes absolutely
i just
purchased a plane ticket for my daughter
she has a hyphenated last name we had to
try six different times to confirm that
she was in the system uh and
so that was just a hyphen and an umlaut
would would would be a good example of
the kinds of problems that can surface
beta
i'm sorry i guess i may not be uh up on
things what
did you say could be a problem what was
the term you used
it's an umlaut it's two little dots
above a letter to adjust the
pronunciation thank you
i learned something new
any other questions
thank you for taking my question uh it
seemed like you were pretty concerned
about false negatives false positives
and stuff
would you uh
would you find this bill a little more
palatable if we put in a grace period uh
you know 30 60 days whatever and in
order for somebody to to defend
themselves against
um if the bill is not necessary e-verify
is not necessary the i-9 process is very
thorough and comes with all sorts of
weighty
consequences for not complying so
e-verify doesn't accomplish anything
that the i-9
thank you mr chairman uh kind of follow
up to that question
um
in terms of the federal requirements on
e-verify are you isn't it the case that
those have the requirements are built
into the federal system when you
register
and
no state law can waive those federal
requirements are you referring to a
possible grace period etcetera right if
we wanted to
mandate
verify but somehow
present a gentler software yeah well i
that makes sense to me i won't pretend
to be an expert but that makes sense to
me that the program is already written
as it's written
sullivan
thank you mr chairman um thank you for
taking my question the um
i'm not an employer so some of the stuff
is uh is new uh i9 is new to me could
you explain in detail what the i-9
document is
yes and i think i'll i'll be smartest to
defer to the representative from the
department of labor but uh as an
employer i utilize the i-9 it's a form
you can download off of the
i don't know if it's which federal
website it is and it requires there are
two columns of documentation that prove
someone's
authorization to work so if you have
something from column one then you don't
necessarily need something from column
two but if you're if you have a document
from
column one that doesn't necessarily
establish a work authorization but shows
your identity then there would be a
second uh column of documents so
it is a it's a very standard part of any
employment process it's a a one-page
i have a few questions please
you said uh 22 states have enacted this
law have any of them have any states
repealed
that's a good question i don't know
that's under utilized in those states
according to the data that we have
are there any new england states that
have this law
that's a good question so the states are
alabama arizona colorado florida georgia
idaho indiana louisiana michigan
minnesota mississippi missouri nebraska
north carolina oklahoma pennsylvania
south carolina tennessee texas utah
virginia and west virginia so no no
states
in your testimony you use the term
humane immigration policies can you
please explain to me what a humane
immigration policy is and do you feel
this is not
yes i do feel this is not but humane
immigration policies
acknowledge the stories that connect so
many of us to our our family's pathway
to the united states it acknowledges
that people are traveling migrating for
very wholesome reasons from economic
opportunity or love or
safety from violence or from economic
desperation in their own countries and
it creates a pathway where people can
fill out an up an application they'll
understand the conditions they get a
timely
review of their case
it's not policies that are motivated by
for-profit prisons and for-profit
surveillance companies which drive so
much of the enforcement behavior that we
see and have seen for decades in the
country not just in the last few years
humane policies would also acknowledge
that when people come to our southern
border fleeing for their lives that we
don't just close the borders that we
have processes where their cases can be
heard
all right thank you are there any other
questions from mrs horwitz
thank you very much thank you
good morning mr chair members of the
committee
thank you for
taking my testimony my name is eva
castillo i'm an immigrant rights
advocate
lived in manchester for many many many
many years
i'm here to speak
against this bill
i'm part of my organist i'm the
director of the new hampshire alliance
for immigrants and refugees that work
statewide and we're part part of a
larger
national coalition and we're part of
this
the organization that gave you the
letter that maggie just uh
read and distributed to you so i'm not
going to repeat uh some of the stuff
that you've heard
the fact is
that
e-verify has not pro proven to work and
to deter
undocumented immigrants from working or
from being hired in states such as
arizona that was the first state
to
the first state to enact e-verify the
compliance is like 60 percent according
to the cato institute
and
what happened was that the wages
were
decreased for undocumented immigrants so
instead of deterring them
to to get employment they just doubled
up and they
got additional jobs to supplement their
their income
this is not going to put a stop and it's
not going to uh to employment of people
that are here without
authorization
the fact is that a lot of industries
depend on the hard labor of undocumented
agricultural the the the meat packing
places the you know and
what are they gonna do without their
employees right now we have a crisis
with the with the pandemic
i cannot tell you how many calls i get
every month
of employers looking to hire people
because they're looking they cannot find
employees so this is going to hurt the
businesses it's going to put an
additional burden on the small
businesses that are already hurting
due to all these covered mess that we're
into it's going to put an additional
burden on them it's going to be costly
for them because they're going to have
to assign a person to to spend some time
uh
learning the system
and
you know using it
but it's not going to be effective for
anything
it's going to subject the businesses to
liability
because a lot and this is not only to do
for um for citizens a lot of
non-citizens are illegal permanent
residents you know we work here i was i
before i became a citizen like 20 years
ago i worked for like
i don't know 15 years or so as a legal
permanent resident
and you know i wasn't a citizen but i
had the legal a legal right to work here
so
the names is another mess
we in latin america we use both her
parents name so i'm eva del carmen
castillo stephanie this is my maiden
name and then when i married my husband
so he said castillo stephanie detergent
so my my you know i came here on a
student visa in the 70s when they used
to give us uh social security numbers
and that's still the social security
number that i use now but that had i
don't know what combination of my names
previous to my married name
so you know it is it creates additional
burdens it burdens the businesses it
burdens the the employees a a lot of
employees that get uh kicked out of the
system for something that they don't get
notified by the company because you know
why why bother there's another an
additional step to say hey you know what
you your your application didn't come uh
back correct they're not gonna bother so
these people are gonna go without jobs
uh it can potentially like i heard uh
the representative said you know
this composer an incentive for
just plainly dismissing people that look
or sound like me well if i keep my mouth
shut like i guess i could pass but you
know that that sound like me
uh or that look different so that could
pose you know present a potential
liability also so for all those reasons
and all the beautiful crafted letter
that we put together and with all the
reasons you know it really makes no
sense in new hampshire to do this to
mandate that in a state whose motto is
live free or die we do not need one more
regulation when we already have
protections uh for employers and we
already have a way to verify who's
working here with what kind of documents
so thank you
thank you ms castillo any questions
for the presenter
representative
thank you for taking my question uh
forgive me if i uh if i didn't
understand you know that sometimes i
have a heart
accents can be um
are you aware of um the the the labor
law violations the safety violation the
health violations that yes the illegal
immigrants uh have to put up with
because they they can't report they
can't report anybody to anyone uh you
know also the the strain on small
business i know for myself um you know
about 15 years ago uh you know i was in
the home improvement business and um
you know i i was
it was january i was given a real cheap
price you know to to rehab this this
building and uh
illegal immigrants came in and cut me in
half uh and all i well the only money i
was making is to uh you know to pay my
help so i wouldn't lose them okay um
the these guys uh that they don't they
don't have insurance most of them they
don't have workers comp they you know
their their their equipment is do you
realize that that stuff goes on and i
realize that because i am a board member
of the new hampshire coalition for
occupational safety and health for over
20 years and i volunteer for over 30
years to interpret at the department of
labor the workers come hearings because
they don't pay for interpreters so
i am boots on the ground and i can tell
you the horror stories of the abuse that
people the immigrant workers have
uh and endure just to keep a job i have
people that have had the the employers
so
the cuts i have people that have cracked
their skull and been in uh been in coma
for six seven months with nothing i and
we had to pack him and send him like a
drag doll back home i cannot tell you i
mean over 30 years i've been doing this
so yes i am very aware of the abuses
that people endure in order to make a
living
so
if implemented correctly
wouldn't a knee verify system uh
help as far as uh as far as the ability
of an immigrant to be able to uh to to
report an employer that's that's
breaking all these laws the laws are
going to continue to be broken and the
fact is that as long as we like maggie
said before as long as we have a sub
class of people
that are continue to be preyed upon
because of their immigration status
these people are going to continue
hiring them and abusing them and workers
have no other choice than to work the
solution is not to put more barriers to
employment because people already are in
dire need to find employees
the solution is to pass a humane
immigration reform that would allow the
people that are here
without the proper authorization to earn
thank you
no questions thank you very much for
i had to call bruno de bruto
new hampshire brazilian coalition to
testify
good morning mr chair good morning
members of the committee
my name is bruno de brito
and i am
an immigration advocate in the state of
new hampshire
i am president of the new hampshire
brazilian council
and i am an immigration attorney
i would like to to start by
giving
a little bit of background on
immigration law
so the the first the first time that the
united states really
started requiring and prohibiting other
people to come to the united states
was through the immigration act of 1924
that excluded certain individuals
from coming into this country
but the law wasn't really established
until
which that was when
um the border patrol was established
today
there that department is under the
department of homeland security
known as customs and border patrol
so
these individuals that came prior to
that
if we apply today's immigration law
these individuals would be
called or you know like some
some people state illegals
some of them would be deemed to
to have a you know
ban called asylees which is someone who
files for an asylum application
and thankfully uh to the constitution of
the united states you would be you know
the babies granted u.s citizenship
through the 14th amendment
it is my opinion that this bill is
in violation of the constitution the the
reason being
is
because the state doesn't have the the
power to enforce
uh federal laws
uh the attempt that the tenth amendment
states that
all the power that that has been granted
to
the
federal government
by the constitution or by federal law
shall be
deemed in the hands of the federal
government all the other powers should
be given to the states respectively and
to the people
so this law is a federal law that the
state of new hampshire is trying to to
pass
and some of you i bet you're thinking oh
yeah but we have 22 states that have
passed this legislation
but uh none of these states the law has
been challenged yet so
we don't know we don't know for sure
um the constituent constitutionality of
this law
so
also as business owners i know uh some
of you are
uh do you really want uh the the state
to interfere with your ability of like
livelihood
telling you what you should and should
not do with your own business
as a business owner
as i have stated um you know like
immigration
uh has not been changed much immigration
loss has not been changed much
from many many years and unfortunately
it hasn't followed the the current
moment that we're seeing
as you all know we have a lot of
employers that want people
uh to to work
but they cannot find anybody and i can
speak to you uh from you know the
immigrant community they're actually
they're scrambling you know to to find
jobs because in the immigrant community
it has been so difficult for for them to
actually get jobs because the typical
jobs that immigrants perform are the
jobs that no americans want to do
cleaning toilets constructions
plowing snow uh landscaping and uh so
forth so it is very you know like
difficult especially during the winter
during covid a lot of families are
struggling to
find jobs because of many circumstances
out of the control
so
in addition we have many many many what
we call
mixed families mixed families which uh
someone in the family either the father
or the mother
most of the time the father
that is undocumented we don't use the
term
um illegal so the term illegal so you
all understand is the equivalent to the
n word
so we don't use that that term
so the father is typically undocumented
the mother is a u.s citizen and they
have a u.s citizen child
so if the father is not able to to get
work the mother has to take care of the
child
uh who's gonna pay the the bills uh you
know the the mothers typically uh
especially immigrant families they don't
like to seek out for for help even
though they have a u.s citizen because
they're always afraid that it might have
a consequence on the undocumented
immigrant in the family so it is a very
complicated uh situation uh immigration
is not easy i'm sure you all see the
calls for immigration reform in the news
pretty much every day it's because it's
so convoluted not even us immigration
attorneys are really understanding
because it changes daily so it's hard to
keep up
but i urge you to vote against this bill
thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
greetings mr chairman
members of the committee
my name is rasha mahmoud i reside in
derry
new hampshire
and i'm a member of the public
i'm here to oppose hb
and i'll tell you some of the reasons
why
but first i want to
[Music]
reinforce
the idea that it's it's no longer
acceptable to use the term illegals it's
not in the text of the bill
from what i've read
um i see undocumented that's an
acceptable term
um but i heard a gentleman earlier
testifying
using this term and
illegals
is not acceptable at a time when this
country is
going through a racial equity reckoning
[Music]
also uh people that are undocumented can
become documented with some federal
immigration reform
so let's retire that term that's my
first point
um secondly i want to say that
this bill is bad for people
for families
for livelihoods and for communities
i'm um
i'm the head of a household of a mixed
status family that mr bruno referred to
so i'm a u.s citizen
um my
several years ago on a student visa
and
we've been trying to change his status
from a student
to a legal permanent resident for about
two years now
and
during that time
we've had a child
and our baby is now one years old and
we're still waiting for his work
permission
we're still waiting for a green card
and
that means that he's undocumented
he doesn't have status
but does he have a right to be here of
course he does
um
he's also a young man who's ready to
work
he's uh he's young he's able-bodied he
has great skills he's educated
and
there
there there's not a possibility for him
to work right now
i expect that he'll go through a
background check
when it's time for him to get hired or
when he finds a job
but i can't understand why it would be
necessary to
perform a background check that requires
reporting
him to the federal government
um
finally i just want to i want to you
know confide kind of personally
um i'm the sole provider at the moment
um i'm a i'm i'm a mom i i work nine to
five
um and
um occasionally we we have to send our
child to daycare
people in new hampshire also have a hard
time getting a driver's license so to
add on top of that difficulty of not
you know not having that extra financial
support from my husband
he also
is not allowed to to drive
you know so you can just imagine all of
the um stress
and financial burden that falls on women
like me it's like being a single parent
so he's just been undocumented and
waiting for two years other families
have been waiting for you know much
longer to get to get status here
why should we take away people's
livelihoods
if they're already here
do
do we want to see families suffer i
um
[Music]
there's job wanted signs
everywhere
my husband can't apply for any of those
jobs
and so
services will go unprovided
and the economy will subsequently be
affected even more by this pandemic so
why should we make it more difficult to
finally i think that it's important that
we leave enforcement of immigration
and perhaps one of the solutions to this
problem is reforming our federal
immigration policies and making it
easier for people to immigrate legally
including you know pathway to
citizenship for
undocumented people and uh
holders of
dreamers tps
refugees let's be proactive about
immigration rather than reacting in this
way so until our immigration system is
reformed i think there's a better way
especially in a live free or die state
rather than putting more restrictions so
i'm urging you all respective
respect
respectfully to oppose this legislation
thank you
thank you for your testimony any
last card i have lexi uh rojas new
mr ross i think you don't you have any
testimony or you just want to answer
questions uh i just wanted to announce
myself that i'm present for any
questions that anyone's available that
everyone has
the department has no position with
respect to the bill we understand it as
written
we do find it would make it easier for
us to enforce our statutes
thank you mr chairman
thank you to the dol rep um
could you explain to us how the hiring
process works for employers employers
are required to get i-9 employees are
required to file with the state within a
certain amount of time and if the
process isn't met what happens to those
employers when they're found under audit
so they're not required to file it with
the state they're required to retain it
in their possession for the duration of
the employment and an additional three
years
so during an audit we would ask the
employer to present the uh the
documentation the proof of the
documentation to work the i9s and then
we would look at it
and just make sure that they had it on
file um
so that so and if they do not have it on
file it is
the employer is subject to up to twenty
five hundred dollar penalty so it's not
an instant twenty five hundred dollars
but up to zero to twenty five hundred
plus an additional up to one hundred
dollars per day per employee for the
duration of the violation
uh usually the duration of the time that
the work was done uh most of the time we
come up upon this situation is
construction
that's where we're seeing an issue with
the undocumented workers or fraudulently
documented workers
and they are often paid less than the
documented workers and we are seeing
less protections for them as previously
testified
thank you so when you come across that
um
undocumented workers
with
fraudulent documentation um
the employer is responsible
for that for taking that fraudulent
information and hiring them as employees
that's tricky um so the issue is and i'm
not sure if e-verify is going to be the
answer either so um but so the how the
we understand the law because we come
upon it
is the employer is not expected to be an
expert in um the documentation but they
are subject to potential penalties if it
was
so obviously fraudulent that it was you
know it airs on the side of negligence
the pictures don't match the date of
births are off the fonts weird
on the fraudulent documentation so um i
think you know it's our understanding
from you verify that it may take some of
the mystery out of it for the employer
so that they're not um
entering into that liability that
questioning on us on our part it adds an
easier step of due diligence um where um
we did have one recently where the
pictures just
just didn't look right
everyone looked like they had glamour
shots uh in the documentation that we
saw um
so you know that it takes something so
the decide that you know the deciding
factor upon the department is whether or
not we're going to try to hold the
employer accountable should that
employer have known better from their
review of the documentation
now e verify i don't believe would have
i think it's you know it's a
government-run um website
in which it would be an easy check for
the employer to determine whether or not
follow up
thank you mr chairman um unemployment
securities requires us to
file with them within two weeks of
hiring a person if that information
comes back
sorry i wasn't aware of employment
security does so department labor
doesn't require filing with us so i want
to clarify that yep
employment securities requires two weeks
for a new employee um what if that
as an employer issue took the wrong
information again fraudulent issue the
dol walks in the door and does an audit
on that employer because es
flagged it
how does that work for the employer
the employer knew it was fraudulent and
continued to operate um so that would be
a question for us to determine through
and it would be through the
investigation whether or not the
employer should have known um if they
continued to operate after employment
security flagged it for them and
informed them that it was that the
documentation was fraudulent
um and it would go through the hearing
process if we couldn't reach an informal
settlement
are called any other
questions for
us
seeing none thank you very much your
testimony i do not have any additional
pink cards are there any
additional individuals who would like to
speak on
this legislation
representative cao you have a question
of the chair uh yes actually it's for mr
avalani if he would please move the
microphone closer because i'd like to
hear his questions because they're
so you know questions of hearing on
house bill
uh 11 24 is closed we will immediately
open
house bill 1165 which i am do not have
any pink cards whatsoever for anyone who
would like to present the bill or not
so
my mother's mad at me because we're not
all right all right
the vice chairman will be stepping in
while i go testify
against
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr chairman
i am andrew prout representing
hillsborough county district 37 the
towns of hudson and pelham
this bill would repeal the granite state
family leave plan that was inserted into
house bill 2 the budget trailer bill
last year
as we all know the budget process last
year introduced many policy changes and
i disagree with this one
while the program was sold as a
voluntary private insurance plan it is
100 taxpayer funded for the 11 000 state
employees covered by it
this cost is not guaranteed to stay
within the rosy forecast predicted by
its proponents
and the taxpayers will be on the hook
for the increased costs when the
contract comes up for renewal
private insurance similar to this
offering is already available and costs
much more
this will also affect county municipal
and school budgets
you may look at the bill and what passed
an hb2 and think
and think that you don't see where it
does that
but it should be obvious that an
unnegotiated free gift to state
employees will not go unnoticed by
county and local government employees
this program will metastasize
and
then it will grow
as previously stated
local governments will be left holding
when the costs on this program increase
not if but when
there will be calls to make the program
mandatory to explain away these
increased costs by selective enrollment
i predict the insurance companies
issuing contracts under the state
program will be at the forefront of
these arguments
what better way to drive more business
to them
unlike unlike how other states have
implemented this idea as a
government-operated program we've set
the stage for crony capitalism
we've set the stage for an army of
lobbyists and campaign contributions to
make sure the program never changes
is never reformed and the overhead costs
pocketed by these companies are never
audited
we don't need programs like this for
companies offer great benefits to their
employees
we're in one of the most severe labor
shortages companies are offering a
myriad of incentives to hire retained
employees
some do do this with better benefits
some do it with higher base salaries
it varies from industry to industry and
employer to employer as it should
government involvement will only make
the situation worse as i've experienced
myself
i work in massachusetts where they've
recently implemented
family medical leave insurance program
and my work decided they couldn't meet
the new requirements on minimum accrual
accrual rate tracking usage and all the
other regulatory burdens under the new
terms of the new fmli plan
which they actually had a waiver from
because they already had a similar
benefit but not from the reporting
requirements
so to meet these new rules they reduced
the sick leave benefits available to
employees that have been in place for
decades
a real life example of of making things
equal in the way described in kurt
vogel's story harrison bergeron
as we all know once the program is
implemented the chance of a repeal
becomes unrealistic it will only grow
like all government freebies the time to
address the problem is now
and thank you for your time
consideration and i'd be happy to take
any questions
i have one
do you have any information on the
status of implementation
since this went into the budget bill
what has happened at the state level so
far
thank you for the question um
i do not know precisely where
uh the department of i think it's in
insurance is in issuing the contract i
know they have begun discussions but i
also know that the contract has not yet
been issued and i know it has not yet
been gone to the governor and council
thank you any any other questions for
the representative
yes
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you
representative i'm just wondering i
wasn't really part of the sausage making
and hb2 i'm wondering do you have any
historical
knowledge of just how this
made it into hb2
thank you for the question um
i can tell you that it was not in the
version of hp 2 that left the house
and it was part of the
senate hearing process that inserted it
and then in the committee conference it
was
uh i believe one of the last items to be
thank you
further
questions seeing none thank you very
next up i have a card from amanda sears
she is representing the campaign for a
okay thank you
getting back into the habit of this
sorry about that
um
so good morning my name is amanda sears
am the director of the campaign for a
family-friendly economy a paid family in
medical leave is important for workers
and businesses in the economy and the
kovid 19 pandemic has only underscored
the value of having a system for
ensuring people can take the time they
need for medical emergencies without
putting their financial security at risk
but the governor's program to
artificially prop up a private insurance
provider is not an effective paid leave
program that meets the needs of granite
staters
what the legislature should do here is
repeal this program and replace it with
one that covers all working people
so we would be in support of an amended
version of this bill that would repeal
and replace the program currently in
statute
as a result of having no public hearings
surrounding passage of this program
there are many problems with this
program and many gaps in information
about access cost implications etc which
would really should really be considered
the governor's program entirely leaves
out a path for employees at companies
with less than 50 employees to access
this benefit if their employer doesn't
choose to offer it and about 40 percent
of new hampshire workers are employed in
these settings
these employees are already far less
likely to have access to paid leave and
are left out of the individual market
entirely
unless their employer decides to opt in
and cover the whole staff
if they do that employer gets the
competitive advantage of saying they
offer this benefit
and they'll enjoy a publicly subsidized
rate and or tax credits but they don't
have any disincentive to deny employees
from taking leave when they need it
and they can retaliate against or fire
employees who try to take this publicly
subsidized benefit
uh there's also a bunch of questions
about people who work for multiple
employers and if you work for one
employer of over 50 and one employer
that's smaller that doesn't
qualify for the individual market and i
think that you know that might open the
state up to legal challenges about
discriminating against residents ability
to access this publicly subsidized
program
because of the size of the company
they're employed by
the insurance companies have a lot of
control with this program over cost of
premiums
rate setting denial of claims and
there's no process outlined for appeals
of denied claims or even jurisdiction
indicating who would be responsible for
those appeals
and private insurers already control so
many of our health care decisions we
would now be trusting them to decide
when and whether we can provide care to
our loved ones with this program
there's no consideration in this policy
about the
several operational questions like if an
employer purchases independent coverage
for medical leave but the employer fails
to grant the employee time off
or what if the employer recognizes the
need for time off but the individ
independent insurer denies coverage how
are these disputes resolved
the state would be acting as a
collections agency for this private
insurer that's chosen
and i've noticed i've not seen any legal
opinions on whether it's okay for the
state to charge low-income people
in the individual pool the same premiums
as high-income earners but to provide
them with significantly different
benefits because how this would work is
that
you know somebody who's a 130 000 a
dollar a year worker would pay the same
would pay the state up to five dollars a
week the same amount that a 12 an hour
worker would pay but these two people
would get wildly different benefits
based upon what their wages are
there's also a bunch of other questions
and probably don't have time to get into
but could answer
bring them up and then this is going to
have a significant revenue impact for
the state that hasn't been considered
and that are not based upon a
consideration of how many people will
actually newly get this benefit
uh you know if if we had 30 percent of
employers in the state take advantage of
that that's about a third of our
workforce a third of our workforce
already has access to this benefit so
you could have a third of our workforce
take advantage of it take a 30 million
dollar hit to the state budget and not
have a single new person have access to
this benefit than has it right now
so the bottom line is
the reason that there's been a demand
for state policy for paid leave is
because two-thirds of working people
don't have it
and there's significant disparity
between who has it and who doesn't
and the people least likely to have paid
leave are working people with the lowest
incomes and the most significant
caregiving responsibilities public
policy should be used to eliminate that
disparity this does not guarantee that
we do that
it doesn't make a commitment uh to
ensuring that we working people who have
paid leave will have paid leave when
they need it
and it artificially props up a private
insurance market without making any
commitment to ensure that people can
take the leave that they're that they
are paying for with this program
i'll take questions thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
seeing none thank you very much
i only had two cards submitted
for testimony is there anyone else
present who wishes to testify in this
bill
seeing none i will
close the public hearing on this bill
we have our next public hearing is
scheduled for 11 45 so we have just shy
of a half hour break
well
thank you mr chairman representative
brian sullivan
representing sullivan district
1 grantham springfield plainfield and
cornish
um i'm here to
open the hearing on house bill 1304
which is
establishing a committee to study the
impacts of outdoor working conditions in
heat and cold
will you plan on testifying on this bill
you
members of the labor committee seeing
that there is no one else here to
testify on behalf
or against
house bill 1304 i'm going to close the
hearing
without objection
all right thank you very much we'll see
you at one o'clock the republican
members of the caucus please meet in
lynn turcotte's office at the end of the
hallway please
300.
yes
folks uh i was just informed that
apparently the representative apologized
for being not being here she has a
medical emergency so
you
but i was had to eat she always wants to
make sure i eat so
all right ladies and gentlemen it is one
o'clock
it's
time for house bill 1337.
opening the hearing on hospital 1337
call the sponsor representative turcotte
you're recognized to speak on your bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
labor committee
excuse me
my name is representative glenn turk i
represent the town of barrington
which is stratford uh county force third
term in the state house
i'm currently a member of the labor
committee as you all know i'm also on
finance
two i'm on the redistricting committee
and also a senior advisor in the house
majority office i'm here to introduce
house bill 1337
on behalf of myself and the other
members of the house majority team who
are co-sponsors to this bill
what this bill
will do in a nutshell
it will tie unemployment duration
to an unemployment rate
that will get folks back to work on an
average twice as fast
it will strengthen the state's trust
fund
over time
and over time it will will or should
reduce taxes on businesses allowing
those businesses to either increase pay
expand benefits or expand their business
the way this bill will work it will
index
the
amount of time on unemployment
collecting unemployment insurance to the
current rate of unemployment in the
state
the bottom number on this will be any
time that the st states unemployment
rate is below five percent
the unemployment benefit
will be 12 weeks which just happens to
be at this time
point of time 12 weeks is the average
that a an individual
an additional one week will be added for
each half percent
increase in the unemployment rate up to
a maximum of 20 weeks
again common sense legislation
uh the unemployment benefits should last
longer when unemployment rates are high
and they should be lower when
unemployment employment rates are low
over time as we as i mentioned this will
increase the solvency of our
a lot of the
in this case florida i sent you all a
extensive white paper on florida and
their results north carolina georgia
are 84 percent more solvent than the
standard states
interesting in that paper i sent you to
florida
when they first implemented this reform
their trust fund was um
in the hole by
1.7 billion dollars
it's currently at 3.9 billion dollars a
net increase of a
5.6 billion swing and their unemployment
insurance rate is
about the lowest in the country at point
one
a couple of things this will do
not only will it help businesses
but it will help
individuals
who are unemployed it's more likely that
they uh when individuals are unemployed
they fall into a longer term dependency
and it becomes harder to find work
and that
studies have always shown that receiving
the unemployment benefits for an
extended amount of time can reduce
unemployed workers job search efforts
decreasing their likelihood of becoming
re-employed i think we've seen over the
last two years an
excellent example of what happens uh the
longer that you
give individuals
uh unemployment the longer they they
tend to stay on um
on unemployment we saw this particularly
last spring
when the federal government was still
handing out 300 a week
unemployment checks
and
they asked us governor sununu would he
continue that
unemployment check of 300 a week and he
said yes
it was very short period of time a
couple weeks later that he reversed that
and that was a on because a lot of the
business and business groups said hey we
can't find employees we need that to end
and by reducing that you can see where
we are today
in the two percent range for
unemployment
as we were just talking about we are
suffering a worker shortage at this time
we need more workers not extended
welfare or
the last numbers that i have show that
as a total percent of
wages the unemployment tax rate in new
hampshire is 0.47
which is good state
countrywide
but you compare that to florida at point
one that's almost five times less
georgia is currently 0.22
north carolina 0.39 and even maine
who is not doing indexing at the time
couple word changes that i will be
introducing amendment
on later
that those were recommended by
the deputy commissioner
and uh
i didn't want to put that forward now in
case there were any other changes that
may come forward
basically it was just some clarification
on the second paragraph b
where we take the snapshot how we take
so in closing
again this is a rational responsible
common sense legislation shorter term
payments when unemployment rates are
high and
longer term payments when unemployment
rates are high and shorter when they low
ultimately this will save businesses
unemployment insurance taxes those can
be used for the benefit employees or
expanding businesses
and as we said we learned during the
last couple years that
a
segment of our population tends to
remain idle when monthly payments in new
hampshire at one time had a high of
thirty six hundred dollars a month
and the final point i'll make is there
is no financial downside to this fiscal
downside
there's only upside for this
and with that i'd be happy to take any
questions
representative warden you recognize your
question
thank you
maybe you're going to just address this
an amendment but in paragraph 2 line 10
of the proposed bill you say uh how to
identify or
define the state average unemployment
rate
and the way i read it it looks like the
three months for the most recent third
quarter so quarter three of the calendar
year average of those three months means
you can only addressed it once a year
correct that's correct um i'm sure
commissioner uh deputy commissioner
lavers will be happy to come up and
explain exactly as i said that um
starting online time 10 we we've
discussed this and he suggested um a
couple changes to that
when he comes up if you would ask him
that question he will be able to answer
it very well follow-up
but just as a follow-up what is what was
your intention
say that again what was your intention
once a year
representative
cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
is the is the economy
the employment rate
doesn't that sort of it's a standard
rate which we say would change it once a
year you know if i measure the
circumstances once a year
but
i think the economy sometimes moves more
often than that
and furthermore i wonder if it's the
economy is the same for every sector of
the workforce
there may be there may be people
in one field for which
employment is very hard to come by or in
another region of the state where jobs
are kind of scarce or more plentiful how
would you what would you say to that
i'd say we need one standard rate we
can't be
putting together hundreds and hundreds
of rates
thank you
yesterday i sent out some material
concerning the trust fund in our state
and i wonder if you might tell me how
new hampshire compares with all the
states that you listed that some of them
are have enacted this and where we fall
in that and further there were some
issues that uh that affected our trust
fund such as
the uh the governor opening up
unemployment to people who were
self-employed
a major major decision that did affect
our trust fund uh well it's a good idea
saves the economy i just wonder like if
things like that that hurt the trust
fund
would you prohibit that in some way
going forward
i will let commissioner deputy
commissioner laver speak to the quan you
know the state of our trust fund right
now i i'm
i am not an expert on that so i'm not
gonna i have no answer for you on that
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
could you explain your rationale if i
understand this correctly the maximum
number of weeks
would go from 26 to 20. is that
what is the rationale for doing that
say the last part i'm having a hard time
hearing you with the mask right
my understanding is
this bill takes the maximum number of
weeks of unemployment from 26 to 20.
what is the rationale for that
just uh off of other model states model
thank you mr chairman uh representative
for context i'm looking at an article
right now that said that from business
insider that said that is titled
president biden gambled that cutting off
federal jobless aid would drive people
back to work the september jobs report
blew a hole through that idea
can you tell me the workforce
participation rate from
governor sununu saying that we were no
longer going to participate in the 300
a week benefit program
and the following workforce
participation rate and did people go
back to work or did these jobs get
filled after that change without looking
at that article and looking over all the
numbers i can't tell you off the top my
i have one question if i might
i want to keep things apples to apples
new hampshire normally has a lower
utilization of workers compensation
weeks because we have the lowest
reimbursement
at sixty percent
um
or versus
uh that's what was working
um yeah actually not i was taking
workers comp for a second sorry we pay
very low
um
is there any compe
you sent us some good stuff on
florida
are we comparable to them
from the standpoint of what they pay and
compensate
compensation because i'm trying i'm just
trying to
have an apples to apples
in addition to commissioner lavers we'll
have somebody else testifying here
shortly who
is very familiar with those numbers so
sure
excellent
any other questions for representative
turcotte
seeing none thank you very much you're
welcome to sit here participate or you
can sit there whatever you like
um
i have a couple cards here um deputy
commissioner libras do you want to uh
speak now or do you want to kind of at
the end how would you like to go about
i'll have you do both i'll have you
speak first and then you can follow up
at the end if there's any
misunderstandings or concerns about
things from other speakers
deputy commissioner richard lauers new
hampshire employment securities thank
all right thank you mr chairman i did
have a couple of things to hand out to
the committee this new layout makes that
very difficult
so
what i can do is i'll get two piles
going around so folks can have that to
refer to
one of them is
just a one pager on our response from
the u.s department of labor when we
submitted the bill for their review for
and i did have one other handout that
was much prettier
uh with pictures uh
not necessarily for what i'm going to
talk about today but just more of a
reference point for the members to look
at um and it's some materials that uh
chairman infantine that we had talked
about at the last advisory council
meeting so wanted to make sure the
members had that
i believe you didn't you email this to
the committee as well
i know i've seen this i think you might
have emailed a portion of it and some of
all right thank you mr chairman just for
the record richard lavers deputy
commissioner of the new hampshire
and just to
before getting into my comments the
department
understands appreciates and
is a uh
really understands that long-term
unemployment is not good for anybody
it's not good for the individual it's
not good for the economy
the first
10 years or so
of my time with the department i
focused my time on reminding people that
we were not just the unemployment agency
reminding folks about our re-employment
services
and all of the work that we do around
training and working one-on-one with
individuals to try to get them back into
in-demand employment and then i spent
two years only dealing with the
unemployment program and probably
defeating all of that prior work so um
we
appreciate the fact that long-term
unemployment is not good for any of the
individuals that we work with
but
right-sizing the unemployment program is
important and by right-sizing the
unemployment program
referring to
making sure that there are sufficient
benefits available
for individuals seeking in demand
employment which might require
new training in entering a new sector
i think employers in this state and
individuals
certainly have an interest in making
sure that individuals are able to
afford to be able to obtain that type of
training
for in-demand employment if for no other
reason
that they are not coming back to the
agency on a frequent basis looking for
unemployment benefits again because they
went into a sector that had a
lower prospects for job growth and those
jobs disappeared so we want to make sure
that it's right sized so we're able to
lower the number of times an individual
has to come over and visit us and file
an application for unemployment benefits
so
that all being said
as
is customary with policy matters coming
before the committee the department does
not take a position for or against this
bill
but we did want to talk about some of
the mechanics of it
when representative turcotte had
indicated
that we've had some discussions about
the mechanics and then also wanted to
talk about some related issues as well
i'll be referring to some notes
just so i don't screw up with some
numbers here but certainly available to
answer questions
from members as well
so mechanically
as i understand the intent behind the
bill
what it's seeking to do
is to base the number of weeks of
unemployment that are available to tie
that or to index that
to the average unemployment rate the
total unemployment rate
over the third calendar quarter of the
prior year
so
when we think about the monthly
unemployment rate that is not a number
that new hampshire employment security
publishes
or is responsible for we have a
cooperative agreement
with u.s department of labor and the
bureau of labor statistics
where that is
issued out to the state by
employment security but the
monthly unemployment rate itself that is
calculated by the bureau of labor
statistics they do that
utilizing the federal household survey
they survey a sample
of households in new hampshire between
12 to 1 300
households that is a point in time
survey they do it during the week of the
month that contains the 12th
and from that survey they then
calculate their estimates for the number
of individuals in the labor force
either you're employed or you're
unemployed in order to count as
unemployed you need to a not be working
and be actively searching for work and
have actively searched for work in the
prior four weeks so that survey is
conducted
by the federal government it is their
survey it's not something that
employment security is out there
calculating on a monthly basis so i just
want to make sure that mechanically we
understand how that rate is calculated
so
according to this bill
we would take the average
of the
total or what we would recommend using
the total unemployment rate which is
that number that people are most
familiar with that is published each
month
you'd average that from the prior third
quarter
and that would be the number that would
be controlling for the following four
quarters
if
that rate were at or below 5
the number of weeks available would be
and then for every half point
above five percent uh the bill would add
an additional week up to a maximum
of 20 weeks
there are uh
representative turcotte and i had have
discussed this there are a couple of
opportunities when the rate that is
first published
that it subsequently is revised
and
because of that revision process we had
made a recommendation on making sure to
use the benchmarked rate
and by that i mean when a rate is first
published so
tomorrow
the u.s department of labor will be
publishing the national unemployment
rate for january later on this month in
a few weeks we will publish the
unemployment the january unemployment
rate
for new hampshire
now when we publish the january rate
we will also
update and revise the prior months rate
so you'll see us in the
press release that goes out you'll see
the january rate and we will also
there'll be a quick reference saying and
the the december rate stayed at 2.6
after revised or the december rate was
adjusted to 2.8
after revision so you have that
first opportunity where you
uh the the rate that was first published
is subject to a revision in that
following month
and then at the end of the year
we go through a benchmarking process um
that is concluded in february of each
year so that's something that's ongoing
right now and drawing to its conclusion
but benchmarking is a process by which
we take the
survey-based estimates which were
published each month for the
unemployment rate during the year and we
compare those against the actual
quarterly tax and wage reports that
employers file when they come to
employment security every month and they
tell us how many people they employed
and how much they paid them so that is
compared against those estimates
and then each february we then publish
the prior year's rates as benchmarked
rates
so those would then be the final rates
for that prior year
and i i walk you through that process
so that we can better understand when
when we
talk about using the benchmark rate you
would want to use that final rate and
not something that was subject to
movement and because of that and because
the process is not completed until
february of each subsequent year
mechanically how i would see this bill
working is that once that was complete
in february
then starting in the second quarter you
would be using the prior year's third
quarter average as benchmarked and then
you would use that number for the second
third fourth and first quarters and then
we would do it all over again
using the benchmarked rate for that
prior year's third quarter so it would
control for four quarters but it
wouldn't be a nice neat and clean
orderly one through four of the calendar
year it would be
you would be doing it starting in the
second calendar quarter two three four
and then that first calendar quarter and
do that process
in
looking at
information relative to to this the bill
our recent
first and foremost our unemployment rate
prior to the pandemic right before this
all starting we were at 2.6
and we are now back to 2.6
our recent historical high
uh prior to the pandemic uh was back
during the great recession uh when we
hit 6.7
that was in november of 2009
through january of 2010. that was at a
time period when the national rate was
right around 10
new hampshire maxed out at that 6.7
percent during that time period
and then prior to that uh back in the
early 90s
1992 specifically we had hit 7.4
so that's kind of some of the
perspective on where our unemployment
rate has been where some of our high
points have been
um
if the the formula
that's proposed here in the the
house bill 1337
if that were in effect right now
we would currently have 15 weeks
available
and
because
where even though i just told you we're
at 2.6
because of going back and using that
prior year's third quarter
you would have the number of weeks
dictated by what that average was for
that third quarter and that would that
would be our our 15 weeks
um
one um
this point of um
comment on on the unemployment rate
itself
the the unemployment rate is what we
refer to as a lagging economic indicator
so it doesn't tell us where we are right
now
it tells us where we were
and that prior month
in that week containing the 12th of that
month when that survey was conducted
and that's an important consideration
when we get into talking about how some
other states that have variable duration
unemployment
benefits
like proposed here
some of the factors that they take into
consideration on on
how
the number of weeks available
change
as i had indicated right now
with our rate at 2.6 percent
we would have 15 weeks available
according to this bill
however if we went back to
the second and third quarter of 2020
because we're we'd be indexing and then
we'd be
tying ourselves to four quarters during
the
second and third quarters of 2020 which
is a time period i've tried to forget um
it was a very difficult time period for
us all certainly for the folks at
employment security um with the
unemployment rate having gone to 16
percent um but the but the
number of weeks available during that
time for state unemployment would have
been 12.
um so that's some of the
um
issues that you can see when you're
utilizing a lagging
economic indicator depending on how long
you're going to use it
um
a changing economy um could still be
subject to controls that were put in
place um
prior um to um
those in that case some significant
changes
um
and
and that's a point that's made just so
that as you're looking at at this bill
and trying to um make sure it
fits well into what we need here in new
hampshire
you know perhaps there's
there's consideration for some
flexibility
indexed rate from that third quarter
how long it controls the duration and
perhaps there's a
some sort of
statutory shutoff switch
that can be temporarily implemented to
try to right-size the duration of
benefits for what you're experiencing at
so
looking at our current statute uh with
uh
20 currently 26 weeks being available
this has been the case since 1951
so an individual coming in and filing
right now if they have a
qualifying separation
if
they have
sufficient earnings
from their base period
they would qualify for up to those 26
weeks and those 26 weeks
would be claimed over a 52-week period
now we do allow in new hampshire we do
allow someone to have part-time work
while collecting for unemployment
and i point that out because
individuals who do have part-time work
and are collecting partial benefits may
collect longer than 26 weeks
and
those individuals have to have a
qualifying separation they have to be
determined
to be unemployed or have a reduction in
employment through no fault of their own
but an individual who's not working they
cannot collect more than those 26 weeks
during that 52-week period but an
individual that has part-time employment
they could be having a partial benefit
so maybe they qualify for 300
a week
but their partial earnings bring that
benefit down to 200 a week they could be
collecting for a longer period of time
however i think both of those examples
both the person who's not working and
the person who's working part-time would
both be subject to the durational limit
based on the index here so uh the 12
weeks or whatever that is as indicated
by the prior year's third quarter
average
now um an individual that's working
part-time you've heard from me before on
this the
they are only allowed to earn
up to 30 of their weekly benefit amount
before it starts to um affect uh how
much they're able to get from
unemployment so
you're able to earn up to 30
of your weekly benefit amount and then
every dollar above that that you earn is
subtracted from your weekly benefit
amount dollar for dollar
so that's how we
currently limit how much someone can
earn
while collecting unemployment states do
that differently new hampshire has that
30 percent rule other surrounding states
i know maine has
sets it at a fixed dollar amount so
you're able to earn a hundred dollars
and then anything above that gets
looking at
just the national picture on number of
weeks available and how new hampshire
compares
there are currently 34 states
that provide at least a maximum of 26
weeks
like new hampshire
but it's only 10 of those states that
have a uniform duration like new
hampshire so
we you come in you qualify
you're
you qualify for a weekly benefit amount
as determined by the table that's in our
statute and then you're able to collect
that amount
multiplied by 26 so up to 26 weeks of
benefits
and 10 states have that as a a uniform
duration
the other states have variable variable
ranges and they're dependent upon
a host of factors
including how much someone earned in
wages during their base period base
period base period being the four
quarters prior to your separation and
filing for unemployment from which we
calculate your weekly benefit amount
from
there are 37
states
that actually
have a variable
duration and that 37 is more than what i
just said before is 34 because
the 34 represented how many had a max
duration of 26. there are other max
durations
for a number of weeks you can collect
but there are 37 states that have a
a duration that is variable
dependent upon those factors
the the most
common
variable that they use again is the
amount that you earned
during your base period during that four
quarter period
how it is commonly used
in terms of looking at your base period
earnings to determine how many weeks of
unemployment you get it is commonly used
to
control duration so that if your
earnings were over
say all four quarters of your base
period you were going to qualify for a
longer duration of benefits
if your earnings were concentrated say
within a single quarter of your base
period now your duration of benefits is
going to be shorter so that's
commonly how they utilize base period
earnings to determine your duration of
unemployment
there are
four states
that have a variable duration that's
based on a blend of factors
that includes base period earnings and
unemployment rate
like proposed here
this would be tied to exclusively to the
unemployment rate uh florida being one
of them georgia idaho
and kansas all have
variable duration
that is tied to both
the unemployment rate and
the amount that you earned in your base
period
it's important to
to remember as uh chairman infantine had
brought up
the amount that an individual is
eligible for in terms of their weekly
benefit amount
in new hampshire compared to our
surrounding states and the in the
country as a whole
tends to be low
right now
an individual
coming in qualifying for unemployment
the maximum weekly benefit amount that
they could be eligible for is 427
dollars
that has been the case
since 2007
when the legislature had added some
additional tiers of benefits to the
statutory table so someone earning needs
to earn forty one thousand five hundred
dollars in their base period in order to
qualify for that four hundred and twenty
seven dollars a week
um that is so if you're earning 41.5
that's about a 54 wage replacement rate
if you are earning at our current uh
private sector
um average
weekly wage that's about a 31 percent
wage replacement rate for those
individuals
and
i point that out just
as a lead into talking about duration
here in new hampshire that has tended to
be the biggest control
on duration of unemployment
in new hampshire has been the amount of
our weekly benefit amount and the
less of a wage replacement rate or a
lower percentage
that it it is currently
with that
wage replacement rate being about 31
of the average private sector uh wage
so uh prior to the pandemic we had an
average duration of 12 weeks so 26 weeks
available
uh
12 weeks was your average duration and
we had about 16 so 1 6 16 of people that
exhausted their benefits are used all 26
weeks
we have a current average duration of
just under 17 weeks
16.8 weeks right now on them on the most
recent numbers
with an exhaustion rate
of 13
nationally the exhaustion rate uh was
currently over 29 percent
and our surrounding states
have exhaustion rates that are higher
than new hampshire is currently
we currently have the seventh lowest
exhaustion rate um in the country so
exhaustion again being how many people
that qualify on an initial claim how
many of them use all of the weeks that
are available to them
looking at overall tax burden um as you
know we spoke and talked last week
extensively about this but our
unemployment program is uh supported
entirely by new hampshire business
i see some nodding heads in here
particularly representative avalani he
knows it very well
prior to the pandemic
looking at overall
ui tax burden
new hampshire had the second
lowest ui tax burden in the country and
that was at
0.14 percent of total wages paid
and it was
0.56 percent of taxable wages because
remember an employer pays on the first
14 000 of annual wages to each employee
not total wages to each employee
uh to compare to uh florida uh prior to
the pandemic uh florida had the lowest
um ui tax burden for total compared to
total
wages paid at 0.12
but
the um
comparison of ui tax burden
when we looked just at taxable wages new
hampshire was at .56
florida was at .66
so very close
to each other
i guess the
what to remember there is that new
hampshire has
historically had a very low
ui tax burden
and one of the lowest in the country
that tax burden has increased
as a result of the pandemic
and you have there's some
information in the materials that i had
provided showing how many people have
collected over the last
two years
roughly we
about one quarter
23 percent
of new hampshire's total labor force
relied upon the unemployment program
during 20 and 21.
it's about 10 percent more so about 13
relied upon the unemployment program and
the great recession
and we had about 25 relied upon it
during our pandemic period
so we have seen an increase in that
overall ui tax burden
but
what you'll see in those materials is
that the average tax rates are falling
incredibly fast
and there's it's not a
coincidence it's it's very intentional
but they're falling at a higher rate
despite having paid
more people in the prior two years than
we did in the prior 15.
you know more dollars went out in two
years than we then had went out in the
prior 15 supported a quarter of the new
hampshire labor force
but when you look at
average tax rates
during the height of the pandemic and
it's the final slide in the the prettier
handout that i provided but that final
slide you'll see that our peak
tax rate during
the pandemic compared to the great
recession
we were about close to 40 percent lower
40 percent lower during the pandemic
despite
those crazy numbers of how much got paid
out and how many people collected
and we're about 30 percent down from
where we were
at our peak so it's falling
it's falling very quickly but again
that's not a coincidence that's
intentional
you folks approved changes as part of
the budget trailer bill
we previously had as one of our solvency
controls on our trust fund that when the
fund fell
there were two 0.5 surcharges that were
added to an employer's tax rate both of
those have been eliminated as part of
the most recent budget
and in exchange for that
the
triggers
or the balance thresholds in the trust
fund at which employers get reductions
to their rate were adjusted
right now an employer gets a 0.5 percent
reduction to their rate
when the fund equals or exceeds 250
million dollars over the course of a
quarter new employers start at 2.7
percent so a 0.5 reduction is
significant
employers then get a one-point reduction
when the fund equals or exceeds 350
million dollars and they get a full 1.5
reduction max reduction when the fund
equals or exceeds 400 million dollars
that 250 million dollar level was not
touched as part of
what was uh changed in the budget the
second and third levels were they were
adjusted up and that was the give and
take of getting rid of the surcharges
in exchange for allowing the fund to
grow to a more realistic solvent amount
during a time when employers would be
better able and better able to afford
supporting the fund rather than hitting
them with surcharges during times when
they can least afford it um
we paid out 350 million dollars in ui
payments
a regular state ui
during the pandemic
there was a discussion earlier about
eligibility for self-employed
individuals
self-employed individuals
were never paid benefits out of the
state trust fund
self-employed individuals were paid out
of one of the federal cares act programs
uh so self-employed did not impact the
new hampshire trust fund from that
perspective our current balance we are
at 195 million dollars
we
never borrowed
during the pandemic
new hampshire did borrow during the
great recession we did not borrow
during the pandemic
according to our current forecast right
now we are forecast to end this year at
285 million
uh and will end 2023 at 319 million
and then 2024 for what it's worth
looking that far ahead
we forecast to end at 354
million
and we are forecasting that that first
0.5 percent reduction to employer tax
rates will kick in in the first quarter
of 2023
typically your most expensive quarter
so that's very timely for employers but
that's what we're currently
forecasting um
with regard to when those fund balance
reductions come back in
so um
i was a little bit all over the place
with a lot of information there i
apologize for that uh this bill does
touch upon a lot of areas with solvency
with duration um but i wanted to make
sure that the the committee um
have that information and certainly can
answer questions now and i'll be here
throughout the duration of today's
hearing um so as other questions come up
i'll be more than happy to try to answer
already
then questions representative avalani
and then representative cahill
representative cahill your
your your counter your fellow
representative will yield his time
thank you mr chair thank you mr lavers
so
is it is it fair to understand my
understanding of what you're telling us
that the new hampshire unemployment
system is working well
and serving the needs of both employers
and employees when they should be when
circumstances change which may happen
more than once a year that something
could happen that uh
that would make the as you as you
decided in the example the the covid
thing we would have 12 weeks under this
legislation which which obviously would
not be enough are we doing okay as it is
um well i have
if the question is whether or not the
unemployment program is currently
performing well i have somewhat of a
vested interest
in that as i sit uh you know second in
charge to commissioner capatis over that
program yes
i do believe the unemployment program is
performing well and has served uh the
state of new hampshire well over the
course of the pandemic
follow up
uh then you're familiar with the phrase
yes very familiar with that thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner i have a couple questions
could you um
tell us the difference between the total
unemployment rate and the insured
unemployment rate
yes so
and you'll see that was
an issue or
not an issue but a
clarification that the letter the email
back from the us department of labor had
pointed out so
your total unemployment rate is the
unemployment rate measured for your
entire labor force that is the
number that people are more familiar
with
those folks here that are familiar with
the insured unemployment rate
i pity you that's a terrible thing that
you're spending your time um in that far
and deep into the weeds like myself
but the total unemployment rate is the
number of unemployed as a percentage of
the total labor force
and that is based on that point in time
survey uh conducted each month where
they ask those households questions
as to whether you are working and if not
when
did you last
actively search for work and that
determines whether you are employed
unemployed or not
in the labor force total unemployment
rate is the number that are indicated as
unemployed as part of that survey the
insured unemployment rate is calculated
weekly
and we look at the number of people that
are filing for unemployment
as a percentage of the total number of
workers that are covered by unemployment
insurance taxes
so
we're dealing with different numerator
and denominators there
and kind of coming at that issue a
little bit differently
and uh that was again something that u.s
department of labor had pointed to in
thank you again mr chairman thank you
again deputy laborers for the follow-up
um
would the iur be
follower um
in case we need to pivot
quickly like we had to do during the
pandemic where we had an automatic
shutoff of workers
on unemployment within a matter of 24 48
72 hours
within
a week you guys were inundated
i know some of those people were would
be
would need more than 12 weeks
but the snapshot would be from the
previous
you know quarters
would that allow you to
move that number quicker so they can you
can extend it out past the 12 weeks to
more
needed
the length of time because i know a lot
you know it's a
it's an excellent question um
so the states that do have variable
duration they tend to utilize
um the total unemployment rate um as
their
control or their index along with
the
base period earnings from an individual
however the extended benefit program
one of the programs that kind of got
overshadowed during the pandemic but
kicked in and was available to
individuals this is the long-standing
federal state partnership program that
individuals can get an additional
amount of time collecting unemployment
beyond the state made available weeks
typically this is a 50-50 shared program
state pays half federal government pays
half
great recession when it kicked in
federal government picked up the whole
bill
during the pandemic when it kicked in
the federal government picked up the
whole bill
the extended benefit program that that
adds weeks on
that utilizes the insured unemployment
rate
it looks at your average over the prior
13 weeks
and if that is and have to go back in
and look at this but if that gets to a
certain threshold
then you would have an additional 13
weeks of unemployment available in your
state
it also looks at whether or not that
average over the prior 13 was at least
120 percent of your iur over a certain
defined prior period
so it's not as cut and dry as just
looking at those 13 weeks
but then it also does if you get to
high unemployment unemployment um and
you uh your iur over that period exceeds
six percent
i believe uh you then qualify for an
additional 20 weeks
so
states
have variable duration using total
unemployment rate the extended benefit
program uses the iur
the um
you know we do also have to remember
that the the total unemployment rate the
numbers that we've been releasing uh
folks that have been looking at the
actual labor force numbers
you've probably been scratching your
head as to wondering why is this number
so significantly lower specifically the
number of people working
why is this so far below
where we were prior to the pandemic
those individuals that are out of the
labor force aren't picked up
by the the total unemployment rate
new hampshire as the region and the the
country right now are dealing with labor
force participation rates that are lower
we're looking at uh probably about uh
when after our
uh the benchmarking process that i
described earlier after that is
completed for the 2021 rates uh new
hampshire's labor force will be off
probably by about two percent
uh from where we were prior to the
pandemic
and so you're talking 15 to 20 000
individuals a significant number for a
state of this size so those individuals
are not in the labor force right now
actively trying to get them back in but
they would they don't get picked up by
yes
thank you mr chairman thank you again
deputy commissioner um so for my math we
have 12 weeks of state unemployment we
have 13 weeks of a 50 50
and then another 20 weeks based upon iur
with another 50 50 with the federal
government
the just to clarify with the 13 and the
20 on the extended benefits it's a total
13 to start and then if you get to high
unemployment they add seven to that not
an additional 20. sorry i realize i
didn't clarify that earlier
thank you so just so basically you had
i'm sorry mr chairman go ahead do you
have you could have
32 weeks of unemployment with the
federal government picking up some and
the state picking up some
overall with the extended benefit
program yes um and there's also um
you know
just to
make sure
you know my testimony is comprehensive
and balanced
during the the pandemic as occurred
during the great recession the federal
government kicked in with federally
financed programs
so
you know
what happened in the pandemic
was not only did the federal government
come in and provide additional benefits
for everyone that was the six hundred
dollars a week that got turned into the
300 a week that got added on to your
weekly benefit amount
but they came in with the pua program
the pandemic unemployment assistance
program
and people that did not qualify for
regular traditional unemployment
because of a pandemic related reason
they moved on they were on that pua
program paid for by the feds
and if you exhausted your state ui
you moved on to a federally financed
extension program
c in our laundry list of alphabet soup
programs from the pandemic but you moved
on to peuc and continued to receive
benefits after exhausting state ui
financed 100
by the federal government now um the
downside to that is you're depending on
the federal government um so there is
somewhat of a risk
in um
basing the number of weeks available
basing that on a dependency or reliance
upon the federal government coming
through
with a program that's going to provide
benefits once your state program
terminates but
that's what the federal government did
during the pandemic that's what they did
during the great recession as well
i'm going to take one no i'd like to
take one last question this is
uh we have other people in these folks
who this is there's a lot of different
questions i'm not sure
well
so i'm gonna just please please
be brief we can always talk to the
commissioner after deputy commissioner
afterwards so um be brief so we can get
the other speakers then we can go back
to
um deputy commissioner if we want
because we do have other hearings to go
to representative medville you're all
thank you um
you went into detail about the extended
benefits that kick in after the 26 weeks
how would those extended benefits work
under this bill
which uh
obviously has far fewer weeks
um so the way that
the extended benefit program works is
and i'll make sure to provide the
statutory site to members so they can
review that as well
but the extended benefit program kicks
in when the state's insured unemployment
rate averaged over those that 13-week
period equals or exceeds
i believe it's set the first level at
three and a half percent
our insured unemployment rate right now
is a half percent because again remember
we're only measuring the number of
people filing each week as a
component of total number of workers
covered by unemployment insurance
so
with the three and a half percent i
average iur
that would kick in the first level of 13
weeks and if your iur was averaged
i believe it's at
six percent but again i need to look at
all right here if i had it all memorized
then i could go right to the page
um
but i'm not that good um but once you
get to uh that six percent average iur
over those 13 weeks then the then 20
weeks would be available and again it's
that
shared financing so half would come out
of the unemployment trust fund our state
trust fund and half would come from the
i understand the 13 and the 20 um what i
what i'm not sure of is um
whether those would kick in after let's
say i think at one point you said the
calculated rate according to these
percentages would be 12 weeks
so basically you would have 13 and 20 on
top of 12.
correct it would be you would
in terms of the the program hierarchy
you would move on to extended benefits
thank you for your indulgence mr
chairman
and thank you deputy secretary lavers so
uh regardless of how many weeks there
are
uh with our
427.00 maximum nobody's getting is true
that no one is getting that comfortable
and staying out of work i mean you tell
us if the average is 12 weeks or 15
weeks that's not a long time to be out
of work because you rex you're not
making enough to make your bills with
our unemployment payment correct
the in the current average weekly
benefit amount in new hampshire i did
tell you earlier the average or the the
maximum amount available is 427 the
average weekly benefit amount right now
in new hampshire's 303 dollars
that just goes to show you that
there's a lot of folks from
lower paying sectors
that are collecting so think of
hospitality think of retail
those folks tend to have
lower average weekly wages hence a lower
average weekly benefit
amount right now 303 dollars
so even at as i'd indicated before the
427 which is our maximum weekly benefit
amount available in the state
that's about a 31 percent wage
replacement rate for individuals earning
at the state private sector average
weekly
wage
thank you very much chairman infantine
uh
house labor committee it's a pleasure to
be before you for the record my name's
gary abbott i'm the executive vice
president gary
i'm the executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
and i'm here today
completely
understanding the concept of the bill
before you
but i think it has some unintended
consequences
and it came to light when we reviewed
the bill with the construction industry
of who i represent
we have seasonal workers in some of our
industries within construction
we can't work during the winter because
of the colder temperatures
it's no fault of the employee it's no
fault of the company
but
many of those individuals go on
unemployment they still are required to
look for work
do all of those things
but the time frame of cutting this to 12
weeks
we know the winter is somewhere between
16 and 20 weeks for seasonal employment
when it comes to for our construction
workers in new hampshire
we see this cut as maybe a
it's problematic for the industry in the
sense of encouraging people to come to
our industry and work for say highway
work and paving
that they know they're going to end up
being laid off
they know that if you reduce it they
won't get even the small amount that we
were talking about in the benefit that
to help hold them over to it but i think
it's uh
there's no doubt my years of working
with the unemployment department
the different tables the different
benefits the way it works and calculated
it's not an easy system in the sense to
come completely comprehend
but we do
businesses
the
state
i can tell you in 2008 a lot of people
come together because when we had the
last crisis trying to figure out how to
make sure
the system stays alive so
i've been there when some of these other
disasters covid was
not something we were gathered by
businesses because the federal
government came in and stepped in and uh
helped but
based on
how this reads at the moment
we don't support it we oppose the
legislation but it's really because of
the seasonal piece there may be ways to
address it and we'd be glad to work with
the sponsor and legislators if there is
a way to
to work with that but i think
we understand how it would benefit
businesses by if you paid less and less
weeks
the whole thing the system
mathematically but we understand the
concept but we're concerned about this
change
and with that i would end my testimony
and thank you very much for the
opportunity
thank you any questions for mr abbott mr
minoval representative i'm sorry
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
abbott um
what
number instead of the 12 would you be
looking for to see
well i think
the
the commissioner stated like what the
average is and that's about where
seasonal employment would be at so i'd
be looking at that and the department
would have the better numbers to really
try to address this what would be the
right number to start at and what would
be the right number to if you did this
formula i get your question i don't have
an exact answer i'd rather have the
department look at
seasonal employers i'm not construction
is not the only seasonal employer in the
state there are many others and i'd want
all of those in that mix with that
discussion that's
really the fair answer
just having some fun guys uh
representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony one thing i'd kind of
like you to clarify for us i know some
people hear that you have employers with
seasonal workers and they want them to
go on unemployment and people imagine
they're trying to save some money by
asking someone else to pay but that's
not how the system works is not
completely how the system works trust me
uh if you're a negative balance employer
you pay a much higher rate with a
different table that's why i say the
system's not the same for each employer
and that's where the the commissioner
talks about people paid but what you
don't see is things like us talking to
d.o.t of whether any of our people could
be a snowplower driver or some other
we're always looking for those
opportunities but when there isn't
when there just plainly isn't
this is at least a safety net and we
understand that as businesses
putting and contributing money into that
system
so i i think
you're right i really appreciate the
question because it's not the same for
every employer and it's not the same for
every seasonal employer
mr abbott for our new new members here
would you just give me a three or four
second tutorial to the people about what
a negative employer is because i don't
think some of these people know um those
are ones in which
uh their payments uh the the benefits
two employees had exceeded so they
jumped to another chart to pay more
than other employers
i hope that explains it because i
but basically they're taking out more
than they put in so they get into a
different chart and they have to pay
more than the average yeah it's kind of
a
you don't want to be in the negative
chart if you can and i think every
any other questions for mr abbott
xenon thank you very much thank you
i apologize in advance for
not pronouncing this person's name right
nicholas
adolfson dolphian
adolphson
nick sorry adolphson
you just got awesome
okay thank you
good afternoon
chairman infantine members of the
committee i am nick adelson i am
from the state north of you in the state
of maine i live in the town of rockport
maine i'm here today representing the
opportunity solutions project i just
want to thank you for giving me a couple
of minutes uh these guys covered much of
what i wanted to cover and
mr lavers probably has forgotten more
today about unemployment than i could
will probably know in my lifetime so you
don't need me to sit here and wax
eloquent on the program but this is
this is an issue that as an organization
we work with states around the country
on and we're working on a there's a
number of a number of bills and we work
closely with
unemployment agencies and legislation
legislators in north carolina florida
most recently tennessee the state of
iowa on this issue specifically and for
us it's all about
getting people back to work and get back
get people back to work as quickly as
possible and so what i want to do is i
want to just encourage you
so
new hampshire is a fantastic state it's
a great state and
i'm a guy from maine proud of being from
maine and so it it ought to mean a lot
here and it come from somebody who who
would like to be a competitor with new
hampshire though i don't think we're uh
we're quite there but it's great for a
lot of reasons
one of the big reasons is that
new hampshire is one of the preeminent
places that says says to businesses and
workers
we want you here
i can tell you that new hampshire serves
as a reminder to the rest of new england
and the entire northeast that
you don't need to be in the sun belt
with warm winters and booming metro
areas like orlando and nashville to be a
leading pro-business state
you just need to continue growing in the
principles you have that you've governed
by over the past decades that's why
honestly and you know this your
competition isn't maine or vermont it's
not even massachusetts or connecticut
it's the
no income tax business friendly states
like florida like tennessee
like iowa around the country
this bill hb 1337 is a statement
that you want to be more than just the
pro-business state of new england or the
northeast but that you want to continue
to lead
nationally on economic issue issues
states like florida and tennessee
already do what this bill does
and they've grown from it florida in
particular tennessee just passed it and
so i'm not going to hash back through
exactly how it works i'm not going to
hash back through the benefits i think
you've i think you've heard those
today already
but i just want to encourage you north
carolina passed this
and i had a had the opportunity to sit
for a long time with the representative
in her office and talk about
why she worked toward this and it was
post-great recession and they had a
disaster on their hands so they had to
fix it
new hampshire doesn't have a disaster on
its hand you guys have done a good job
tennessee passed it last year not
because they had a disaster on their
hands but because
they want to be the best they want to
keep drawing businesses to their state
and i would encourage you as the leaders
of the state of new hampshire to follow
that path and i i am happy to take any
seen thank you very much this morning
appreciate it
mike summers new hampshire lodging and
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
mike summers president ceo of the new
hampshire lodging restaurant association
i'll be very brief um i am no expert in
the details as uh deputy commissioner
lavers has given you uh way more content
that i could i didn't even absorb at all
but uh that said i
in discussing this bill with my board
leadership they asked me to be here
today and really just weigh in in
support of this as a concept um
obviously there are way more minutia and
details that need to be worked out but
they did ask me to be here to speak to
this they feel that it's kind of a
common sense approach it's a very new
hampshire kind of a unique sort of
approach um the one thing that i will
add in listening to uh deputy
commissioner labors is he i think he
alluded to the fact that maybe there is
a way to or maybe there should be a way
to build in some sort of a shutoff
switch in the event that we have another
pandemic
as you know the hospitality industry we
just got crushed by this thing i mean we
were shut down
open one day shut down the next so maybe
there is a way that you know within the
system we could build some sort of a
safety valve in there um so that is the
only comment that i would make beyond
that i'm happy to answer questions and
thank you so
welcome
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i'm roy schweitzer from
concord i retired from the state like
nine years ago and since then i've been
volunteering with a group that helped
people find jobs you may have seen our
notices in the concrete monitor or the
insider
anyway uh
you know part of the problem with this
is a structural imbalance there are some
you know jobs that
there's a shortage of people so
you know it seems like
people aren't looking for work and but
that's because people aren't qualified
for them then there's jobs there's a
surplus of people in so those people may
stay unemployed longer and the
particular thing we've found is a lot of
our people are in their 50s and over
there's serious discrimination against
older people companies just don't want
them
i mean i know a woman used to be a legal
secretary she can't find that job
anymore but she can't even get a job as
a restaurant hostess because they want
someone young and perky and
another example of this is
i used to go on plant tours before the
pandemic and there was a high tech firm
said we have seven jobs we can't fill
i said well that's funny i looked at
your website this morning and there's
only one job posted on how seriously
you're trying to fill those seven jobs
you know
so i think that you know this
company saying they need workers
is maybe a little bit
exaggerated i mean once again i know a
guy who can't get a job at dunkin donuts
and so they say we need people well
people show up but if they're over 50
they won't hire them
so
and this is getting into something i
want to talk about and that is that
as the gentleman with the seasonal work
says you know there's different
you know difficulties with people
getting work
and if the purpose of this bill
is to cut the state's budget well sure
you start off by saying we'll only you
know give the average number of weeks
people get well let's save you half your
money right away
you know two more years you do it again
you say well
12 weeks is too long because the average
is only eight now so we'll cut it back
to eight and then do it to six and four
and you know pretty soon you can
the company don't pay anything at all if
you want to just keep cutting it back
but if you say you know part of the
purpose of this is to help people who
are unemployed and need help
then that's kind of a mistake
i think some people may be feeling that
there are people who abuse the
unemployment system i'm sure that's true
i'm not going to deny it at all
but there are people that really need
help
and
that's kind of another issue i have that
i wanted to come here today
i looked on the website for new
hampshire works
that's the
job seekers interface to
the
employment security
and i discovered that their new
hampshire works offices are open
8 to 4 30 monday to friday
except when i went to the office i
discovered there was a sign on the door
it's only open 12 to 4
and you can only stay there for half an
hour
so you know if there are these
unemployed people that are trying to get
help finding a job you know
why are we
cutting back the
i don't the employment assistance part
of the department by over 50 percent now
they don't have the real job fairs
people can go to they have the virtual
job fairs those are usually 11 to 1. so
if the office doesn't even open till
noon you already missed half the virtual
job fair if you show up at the
new hampshire works to get a job so you
know what i think you really need to do
if you're afraid of these malingering
types or whatever
and say okay you know we'll be kind of
generous we'll give everybody you know
six weeks eight weeks whatever and you
fill out the forms and that's okay
but then once you start running over
that let's give you some real help
and now maybe if you're in a seasonal
industry that real help is going to be
less you know well your employer is
willing to pay a high unemployment rate
so we're not going to really make you
find something because they're willing
to pay for this but
maybe you know this person needs
advice on getting a job maybe you need
to start comparing them with the jobs
they're applying for as in if a
restaurant that keeps claiming they're
not getting any workers is turning these
people down you need to go back to the
employer and say look what's going on
here
so
i think we need to reopen the new
hampshire works part of the
unemployment system and i'm sure the
deputy commissioner can give you some
advice on that why it is when
employers are short of help that we're
not having the offices open so people
can apply i mean half an hour i don't
know how much time most you people spend
on the internet but you know just
checking your email for job leads or
going to a job site you probably can't
do that in half an hour
and then let's say you have to fill out
an application all the applications are
online now and they tend to take an hour
to fill out how do you fill out an hour
application in half an hour and remember
you've already used up your time just
checking the email to find it
so
i think i'll be happy to hang around and
hear just what the deputy commissioner
has to say about why we're not doing
more to help people get jobs that's the
way i see to cut the you know expensive
unemployment compensation is not simply
to say well these people are malingerers
let's pay fewer weeks let's help these
people find jobs
and
any questions for the speaker
representative cahill i know you're
itching ask questions
uh thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you sir for taking my question i
i i wanted to thank you actually because
i earlier today i brought up the
question about whether or not
it was different in you know the
unemployment rate was different than
coast and it is in rockingham and i
really neglected to think about the age
and the skill set of the people who were
out of work
so i really appreciate your coming in
and telling us about that it's an
important thing i i do want to defend
the commit the deputy commissioner i
think they may be having trouble
staffing like so many other people are
but i'm sure he'd be willing to take
your input so it was really more of a
comment and a thank you than a question
but again thank you very much can i
respond to that
would you believe yes you may believe
yeah
okay i mean first off it just depends on
how things are we used to have people
where engineers show up because new
hampshire after the great recession was
much slower to
do construction projects
so one of our gentlemen actually had to
go down and work in massachusetts
because they had much more engineering
work
but he lives in new hampshire and
commutes down there every day and that's
kind of a wasteful resource and
but now you know new hampshire's kind of
caught up on that
and you know the other thing
is
i would be happy to hear the deputy
commissioner tell us that yes we have a
problem with resources but isn't that
your job if
the reason people aren't being able to
find work as the
department doesn't have enough resources
then you've got to increase their budget
or whatever it takes to do that
thank you
cnn thank you very much
mr berkey
welcome
you mr chairman and members of the
committee for your record bruce berkey
with sheen finding capital group and
here today representing
the national federation of independent
business over 1400 small business owners
here in the state of new hampshire are
members
and just two points
one is that like the new hampshire
lodging restaurant association we do
support
this bill in concept
uh perhaps it needs some some work with
respect to a safety net or you know how
it how it you know fits in with the with
the federal uh
you know how it's complemented by the
federal support
but we have seen this work in other
states i know florida and georgia and
tennessee have been mentioned
um and and my counterparts with nfib
down there have have said this is a good
approach to the issue
so we support the measure
the second point i'd like to make um
and and it's uh not necessarily related
to this bill directly but it is related
to deputy commissioner labor's comments
and
i i don't think he would take issue with
what he said
but i will take issue with what he said
when he said that he would like to try
and forget
about
the experience that he
and his staff had in the spring of 2020
i think we should all remember
the experience that he had and his staff
had in 2020 because they performed
outstanding service to the state of new
hampshire
and it was just
i've i i first worked for this new
hampshire house in 1982
so i've been around here for 40 years
i've never seen a state agency
respond in the way that they did
to serve the state to serve the people
of the state in such a short time frame
and in such a emergency type situation
so i just want to publicly applaud
his department with the leadership of
commissioner coppatis and deputy
commissioner labors and the whole team
over there thank you mr chairman
thank you man thank you for your kind
word representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
berkey and thank you for saying that
what you just stated about the
department uh i had many many
constituents reach out to me
and mr lavers was very responsive and
they had they have done admirable work
my question i would believe that
yeah
yes my question is
do we have a problem
like like they said they had in florida
and these other states do we have that
problem here in new hampshire with
people
really laying around and
collecting lavish
unemployment benefits and being
discouraged from working
i think i i don't have any specific
examples for you today representative
cahill um but
i heard some
experiences from
small business and medium-sized
businesses throughout the state of new
hampshire during the the process
so my answer would be yes i think we did
uh was that what you were referring to
the period when the federal government
was sending out 600 an extra six hundred
dollars and
allowing other people in a sort of
unnormally uncovered employers to
collect benefits is it the coveted
period you're referring to or pre-code
it was the covet period
thank you thank you
any other questions for mr
berkey seeing none are there any
additional questions of deputy
all right is there anyone else who's
like to speak on this bill
good afternoon i apologize for the late
card i wasn't planning on speaking but i
just feel like there are a couple things
i'm don mckinney i work for new
hampshire legal assistance
and i feel we've we have um
a project where we've been assisting
folks with
unemployment access to unemployment
benefits um
we've had the project for a long time
it's been uh
incredibly busy over the last two years
trying to assist folks
in accessing benefits and i would echo
everyone's comments about the work that
the department has done
um
and i was just jotting down notes and
now i can't find them
sorry
um
i guess i i
i think what it it comes down to is that
i just wanted to kind of um
highlight a couple things i've heard
that i think sum up what our position is
on the bill which is we feel like it's
unnecessary
it's just it really is a solution in
search of a problem as you've heard from
the data that the deputy commissioner
shared
unemployment is low in our state the
duration of people on unemployment is
low in our state the benefit of amount
the the folks that and then this is
getting to the kind of last points that
folks were making
the folks that are still on unemployment
after 12 weeks tend to fall into two
categories those that are older adults
who are having difficulty finding work
that they're skilled for in some cases
and then also those that have limited
availability um based and that generally
falls into categories of people with
limited access to child care which i
think everyone has probably heard about
during this pandemic it's really
incredibly difficult to access
a reliable child care
and with even if you have reliable child
care there are difficulties in terms of
throughout the pandemic
folks having to
to
isolate
when there's exposures at the child care
facilities etc so
the folks that we're talking about that
are on for more than 12 weeks i think
have specific challenges and barriers
that
[Music]
are i wouldn't characterize anyone who's
on unemployment for more than 12 weeks
as someone who is
in any way taking advantage of that and
i
i think
that i can speak to that specifically
because the
for two reasons one
people are trying to make ends meet when
they're on unemployment they're in a
difficult situation where they've lost
their job and they're trying to continue
to pay their bills feed their families
pay for child care um
keep their car and repair so a good
repair so they can get to interviews etc
and get to work et cetera
and the fact of the matter is they can't
afford to be unemployed as we heard
they can't pay their bills on
unemployment and
they can't afford to be even more so
than not being unemployed they can't
afford to be without unemployment um on
the chance that someone is 13 14 15
weeks
on unemployment which this bill would
ramp back
the folks that are on unemployment those
extra
weeks
you're potentially by ending that
looking at
the ripple effect of that in terms of
um people becoming potentially homeless
because they're unable to pay their rent
or their mortgage or et cetera so it can
kind it compound the problem and
we all know we have a housing problem in
our state so
um
i guess i would just say that uh
we again we we think this is just a bill
that's a solution in search of a problem
and would strongly urge the committee
not to
not to support it
thank you
xenon thank you very much is there
anyone left here in the in the room that
would like to speak on this bill
13 37
saying no i'm going to close a hearing
when you try to get caught up in the
next two bills lightning round and i'm
going to head over to brian for a moment
thank you mr chairman uh so next up we
have the
uh house bill
i do not have a pink card from any of
the sponsors
i see
so
representative lanzera uh prime sponsor
of this bill
um if you could introduce your bill
please
hello
excuse me thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee i'm
representing tom lanzaro from nashua i
come before you today to introduce house
bill
1415 an act relative to employer health
screening reimbursement
what this bill seeks to accomplish
is to amend rsa
to include reimbursement of
pre-employment expenses and employee
expenses
as the statute stands currently it
relates only to an already employed
employee of an employer
hb15
excuse me 1415
only
to an already employee excuse me
will then allow a potential candidate
for employment to seek reimbursement for
expenses
incurred as a condition of full
employment
while many employers contract with
health systems laboratory centers
for their pre-employment needs the
current rsa does not take into account
the cost of the employer's candidate for
the total encompassed cost of
pre-employment such as mileage tolls and
transportation
thank you for your time
thank you
any questions
for president babalani
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative lanzarra um could you
specify it says
is this for employees or is this for
pre-employment screenings because you
said it two different ways
it would include
the candidates that are chosen by the
employer
and
in continuing
thank you
thank you um
if i may clarify on that question i'm
i'm looking at the text of the bill
i see references to employee i see
references to employer
could you help us with the line
i think you'll have to follow up with
that all right thank you
seeing none thank you very much
thank you again
next up i would like to ask lexi rojas
representing the hampshire department of
labor and uh
thank you
um
i'm lexi ross i'm an attorney with new
hampshire department of labor and we
understand what the intent of
the bill is um we have no position we
are confused by it
so rsa 275 3
does state um
it shall be unlawful for any employer as
defined by rc274 2754 excuse me to
require an employee or applicant for
employment to pay the cost of medical
examination or the cost of furnishing
any records required by the employer as
a condition of employment
could you get a little closer to the
microphone we're having some trouble in
the corner yeah so there's
rsa2753 does already
protect applicants as a condition of
employment
uh from having to incur costs there's
also rsa 275 57 which is i understand
what they're trying to amend but it
already broadly addresses this issue
although not specific to applicants we
do have rsa275 iii
there's a labral 80302
subsection b that also us
specifies um
as a specificity excuse me additional
detail with respect to these types of
laws
um
and 275 48 makes it illegal for an
employer to mandate an employee to incur
a cost to the benefit of the employer so
there are statutes already in place to
protect employees in these situations
that is how the department labor
interprets the law currently is to
protect employees in this situation and
potential employees the applicants
um
we do have get a number of calls we were
flooded with calls during the pandemic
with questions about whether or not the
law
mandates employ employees to uh incur
protects employees recurring costs for
testing especially covet testing
and that was our interpretation at the
time as well
i believe the special circumstances of
the pandemic led to employers becoming
confused but our laws did address it
already
so we are confused that we believe that
this bill to be duplicative of the
statutes that are already in place
any questions thank you for the
testimony uh
questions i'll start with representative
prout
thank you um do you see anything new in
this bill uh specifically regarding the
payment for travel expenses right to the
medical examination or the test or
anything else is that already covered or
would that be new it's already covered
where mileage is to be reimbursed
so the employer can so for instance if i
were employee i can't say i want to get
my test in florida so i can get a free
trip to disney while i'm out there
um
the employer can say you know please get
your testing at the rite aid down the
block to help save on cost um but uh
they are to
to to to to reimburse for cost of
mileage
thank you um
um what was the sectional rule uh you
you said the number very quickly oh my
apologies
so there's um labral 803
02b so 0.202b
um does specifically address the mileage
issue as well i can read it too i have
every employer shall provide his or her
employees um oh sorry that's wrong
80302.
pursuant to
rsa27548 no employer shall require an
employee or applicant for employment to
pay for the cost of medical examination
non-required drug or alcohol testing
records required by the employer or any
item required by and for the benefit of
the employer as a condition of
employment
this shall not include examination
permits or licenses required by the
so there are specific so it's already
protected so we are confused
thank you
representative pamela
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking the questions
um you referenced in 80302b
275.48
yes 275.48
if you look at it makes it illegal for
an employee under i
sub section i know it's a long statute
that one it is
i is the date the recovery of
overpayment will begin and end
sorry no sorry 275 subsection um so it's
275 colon 48 i and then it goes starts
off with one and if you go into
i read it this morning double check it
was in there um i should have brought in
so it's 12 for the purpose for any
purposes in which the employer employee
mutually agree that does not grant
financial advantage to the employer
so here
if you're mandating an employee go get
testing
it's the financial
benefit of the employer not to incur
that cost
so they can't so even if they both agree
to it
they're not legally able to do that the
employer has to pay for the cost of
travel to get that testing
so
you can't force someone to get a test
without having to um incur the cost
associated with going and getting that
testing done
thank you mr chairman um so just to be
clear um
health screening is covered their time
there and from is covered if it's during
their work hours
their mileage is covered unless they're
using a company vehicle even if it's not
during their work hours they're to be
reimbursed including mileage
so yes
you get all that
so
i didn't hear that so even if it's off
there if so if i tell you to get a on if
you don't if you're not working on a
saturday and i'm your employer and i
mandate you get a test before you return
to work on uh monday only time you can
get it is that weekend
i am supposed to i am responsible for
making sure that i reimburse you and pay
thank you thank you i didn't know that
seeing none thank you very much for your
your input
i have one more card
kate horgan
representing the new hampshire
association of counties
thank you mr chair members of the
committee my name is kate horgan i
represent the new hampshire association
of counties which is all of your elected
and appointed officials we are also
confused by the bill um but i will point
out that the current language doesn't in
the bill does not include any
pre-existing relationships that we may
have with providers so for example a
coveted test at the nursing home you
if we're in outbreak we're required to
so you have to have a test to come in
we're offering that test
for free
at the at the nursing home for you to
come in it's all set there's no mileage
you're already coming to work you're
good to go take your test move on this
bill would allow somebody to go
somewhere else get a test and then
require the insur or require the nursing
home to pay that bill for something
we're already offering for free so based
on those reasons we are opposed to the
bill and we also believe it's already
covered under current statute so i'm
happy to take any questions
all right thank you very much are there
questions
i do not see any questions so thank you
again
um i do not have any other pink cards
for this bill is there anybody
in the audience who it wants to speak on
i do not see anyone so i will close the
hearing on
hb 415
and
we are already into
um
so i will begin the hearing on that do i
no
all right so to introduce house bill
1472 i have tony lebron
uh they i believe you're the prime
sponsor i am indeed thank you
uh and good afternoon house labor
committee um for the record my name is
uh representative tony lebranch and i
represent the town of amherst and i come
before you today to introduce house bill
which would prohibit employers from
conducting certain anti-union activities
because this bill is short i'll just
read it out to the committee
anti-union activities prohibited no
employer shall promise threaten or take
any action
to permanently replace any employee who
participates in a strike as defined by
section 501
parentheses 2 of the labor management
relations act not prohibited under state
law
b to discriminate against an employee
who is working or has unconditionally
offered to return to work for the
employer because the employee supported
or participated in such a strike
or c to lock out suspend or otherwise
withhold employment from employees in
order to influence the position of such
employees or representative of such
employees in collective bargaining prior
to a strike
section two of the bill
no employer shall engage in anti-union
training of any kind including requiring
or coercing
an employee to view a video that casts
unions in a negative light
this bill would simply strengthen
worker protections and creates an
environment where workers truly have the
freedom to choose whether they would
like to unionize or not
currently many workplaces such as target
walmart american eagle home depot amazon
all require new employees to watch
anti-union videos in their training
this creates a bias in the workplace
against unionizing
for example let's take american eagle
where i worked
it was a primarily staffed by those
beloads the age of 24.
many of them it was their first job
i want you to imagine this a 16 year old
it's their first job they've never even
heard of a union
and the first time that they ever learn
about a union is through this training
that paints unionization in a negative
light
this bias taints any unionization effort
that could come about i personally
believe the only time that there should
be any campaigning one way or another on
unionization is during a union election
this bill would simply level the playing
field and remove anti-union bias from
the workplace so that workers can make
up their minds on unionization without
an undue pressure by the employer
with that i ask that the committee
passed this bill with a not pass
recommendation
thank you very much are there questions
i don't see any questions so thank you
again for your testimony
i have a card
again from the new hampshire department
of labor lexi rojas
thank you
so the department of labor understands
the bill we take no position on as i
stated in the card um we just wanted to
make it clear that our reading of the
bill is that
it does not change our current penalty
provisions in that if this were to if an
employer were to violate this and
someone were to lose employment or
not be given a position because of this
bill
the
per the employer will be given 30 days
to correct a 30-day warning
uh and the only recourse we'd have in
addition after that if they did not
correct it was uh
a 2500 fine up to 2500
so i just wanted to make that
clear
thank you for your input are there
i don't see any hand so thank you very
much thank you
and those are i believe the only two
cards i have on this bill
we're getting kind of thin in the
audience if there's anyone who wished to
i will
close the hearing
we have
only one more bill left for the day
uh that is scheduled for 3 15.
so we'll take a half hour break and
can i have everyone's attention please
um
is this yours representative sullivan
thank you
yours is offered instead
1385 is credit
okay i got 10.76 everyone should have
the following amendments 1076
1386.
that's the eaton cold
and then we have
then you have one from
mandeville
1207. so everyone should have those
three and then i'll hand out another one
for another one that's not happening
do you have a lot of copies
would you
would you plea
yeah go down to heather you know who our
okay
no i got those representative mandeville
i was trying to keep with our schedule
here
i will
i do
so can i give them to him first
thought it was in my car
it's not my car not in my briefcase i'm
appleless
has everybody seen the schedule for the
february
10th
all should have been emailed to you
okay
we were talking earlier i believe we're
we're not gonna we're gonna have a house
session on the week of the 15th um i
believe this to
the state of the state or whatever by
the governor and then we'll have a house
session so i will not have any excuse me
yeah full house session so it would not
be a committee
i will
a list of all the bills
um we're going to exec
um
i might exec a few more we'll see how
many uh we get to today
but we'll at least get to the ones we
have to and the ones we have the
amendments
okay we're a minute late sorry mom we're
going to open the hearing on house bill
and recognize representative lebranch
hello house labor law committee again
today
um
for the record my name is representative
tony the branch and i represent the town
of amherst
i believe at the previous public hearing
on the cacr that accompanies this
there are a lot of issues that were
brought up with the bill and with that i
ask that the committee itl this bill
um
sorry i just want to
are there any questions for the
representative
representative thank you mr chairman um
would a motion to itl this bill be out
of order
oh it's going to executives uh i mean
if you could hold that motion for a
moment please i was just just asking if
it would be out of order it would not
wait
no
thank you
all right so uh like we are done for the
session for the day
i'd like to move into some um
executive
excuse me we're done with our hearings
for the day i'd like to move into
executive session
there's a lot of moving parts here and
i'm going to try to do things in his
best order as i can
so bear with me because i have a lot of
there are a list of
um
bills that i had told you that i wanted
to exact today
if we get through those i'd like to
execute a few more
so
again
give me a couple minutes here i have
misplaced
i'm going to go
the the two early bills first that is
okay with everyone and then we'll move
on to some other ones
and i will try to go numerically if i
can
1207.
i would recognize
representative mandeville
yes uh thank you mr chairman i'd like to
move for uh
um
and
also pass with an amendment on uh 1207.
seconded by us
diesel vestro
you may speak to your motion
thank you mr chairman
um
the
um amendment that is offered
uh
has as its objective let's say the
greatest need of uh
addressing the
um
unlikely but um uh possible uh
circumstances where it's difficult or
even impossible for
a
an employee to get to the polls to vote
on on voting day
there are
precedents for such a bill as amended i
haven't actually found
bills that are
similar to the
sorry
um
you were going to make some copies of
this it was passed around
so why don't you just give
give us a minute to get these out please
certainly
thank you
as i was saying that
the need addressed here is the unlikely
but possible situation where uh
uh employees are
uh unable or it's extremely difficult
for them to get to the polls on election
day
there are as far as i could find no
other states that had a bill quite like
the one originally presented but there
are 29 states that have bills
very much like the one
presented by this amendment including
states such as kansas texas tennessee
oklahoma and particularly utah on which
this bill is primarily based not
entirely but it's very similar
one thing this amendment would do would
be to correct an error that everyone
perceived in the bill when it came up
for hearing
and
instead of it indicating that an
employee would get at least three hours
off
this
amended version states that an employee
would get up to two hours off
in addition it gives the employer
the right to get advance notice and
select the time off although an an
employee would be allowed
to ask for two hours at the beginning or
the end
of
the shift or as much or as little part
of that as they would need
and
importantly it excludes all employees
that have three consecutive hours
not on the job while the polls are open
now that provides a variety of
protections for employers
first of all most employees i'd say
probably the vast majority of employees
would
have three consecutive hours not on the
job when the polls are open so in effect
this would apply only to the
the
employees who are most at risk of not
having time to get to the polls to vote
secondly
it would provide protection in the
context as was asked at the hearing
in in relation to part-time employees
because
it's almost unimaginable that a
part-time employee would not have three
consecutive hours when polls were open
when they were not on the job thirdly it
would protect in the context as asked
about also at the hearing of
employees that might have more than one
employer because this
amendment addresses
a situation where an employee
um is
uh has three consecutive hours while the
polls are open not on the job and that's
important language because if you have
two jobs each one is protected by that
the job is the job in question and so no
employer would be asked to bear the
burden of an employee having
multiple jobs that precluded him from
getting to the polls
the um the greatest value of this um
amendment as i see it is that
it allows as i said that allows those
who would legitimately struggle to get
to the polls to have a little bit of
opportunity to do that and it would also
um
indicate the value and importance of
voting in uh democracy by conveying that
message
and i might say to some of my friends
here that it would also potentially act
contrarily to the idea that we need some
kind of national
day off for
election days
by virtue of providing a sensible
alternative to that
to work in the circumstances where it is
most needed and so finally i would ask
if this amendment could be allowed to
proceed i think we would find ourselves
with a more thoughtful approach a more
appropriate approach and one more
consistent with the majority of states
in this country to allow consideration
of this up to two hour rate
under certain circumstances to have uh
time to get to the polls thank you mr
chairman all right thank you any
additional any comments anyone else like
thank you mr chairman just a question um
for the three or more consecutive hours
between the time
polls open and close
um so this would preclude people that
worked nine to five if the polls were
open seven to seven there would be they
would have to have an extra two hours
off or am i mistaken
up to two hours
up oh even though the polls are open two
hours before and two hours after their
job service that's the way it's written
there are some other states since you
asked and i appreciate the question
that do address it that way two hours on
either side
that's an alternative to three uh
consecutive
um i i would
so that's that that would be an option
but that's not what's here
thank you
i have a question so there's still the
concept here from the last sentence is
that still
um
employer
pays the hours for regardless correct
the
large majority of states that have this
law or
an equivalent of it have that not all of
them although
the
law review article i looked at it as
suggested it was implied in all of them
thank you mr chairman um just a math
question
um so if
if it's three consecutive hours
and in the previous
situation there was two hours before and
two hours after
would that mean the employee would
employer would only have to pay
for one hour
because that would be
that's not the way i i understand this
or intended to draft the the idea is
that the employee is allowed up to two
hours
that
signifies that
they they would take what they needed
um that might be
um that might be 15 minutes that might
be an hour that might be two hours it's
representative proud
um
following up on that how would they
how would what they need to be
calculated because you know it says that
they can be allowed to take it at the
end of the workday if they're concerned
about a long line and want to have the
full two hours just in case
would that the employer be required to
uh to grant that and out of the concern
for the long line
if the employee is not exempt by virtue
of having had three other hours
available then the answer your question
is yes
the
again as
this is partly
a matter of employees working with
employers there are plenty of employers
that do this voluntarily obviously this
wouldn't
affect those that would want to do
things voluntarily would only deal with
the ones where there might be a problem
and the idea at the end of the day for
example in a place if there is any and
i'm not familiar with it but if there
were that one was confronting a long
line that would be actually a good
example of a need for time off uh in as
convenient a way as possible
to to vote
so but to answer your question yes
um but it also would depend on
discussions between the employee and the
employer
any other questions president cahill
thank you mr chair um and thank you
representative
in my town and i'm not sure this is
unique but in my town the moderator if
there's anyone waiting in line
everyone waiting in line gets to vote we
don't close the door
at the time which is everybody who's in
line
but i i applaud the effort that uh our
new our new member not newest but new
member
has put into this amendment it's
something that many employers do as he
said voluntarily uh but he's done a lot
thank you uh representative mandeville
unfortunately um i have a problem while
you did a great job putting this
together i appreciate it especially as a
first-time representative in the first
couple weeks here so kudos to you
this can't get over um
asking employers to pay with absentee
ballots and other things available
um we could be very careful in here
about trying to put too many mandates on
employers so i can't support you but
thank you uh really for your efforts so
unless there's any other questions i'd
like the clerk to call the role the
motion on the floor is on to pass
sullivan
i guess a couple things um
first of all we don't have a uh no
excuse um absentee ballots so
some people who
maybe were surprised by a schedule
change or something like that wouldn't
have an opportunity to get an absentee
ballot
um and uh i also believe that this is a
dramatic improvement over the original
bill and i guess i would ask my
colleagues to support the the amendment
um
because it's simply a piece of good work
and
i i also commend the representative for
the effort he put into this thank you
love
thank you mr chair and uh just like the
chair i have the problem with the uh
with the mandate on employers if uh if a
small business had 25 employees and and
a small
hourly rate of you know hourly rate plus
plus the benefits of say 20 an hour it
cost that small business a thousand
dollars that day i can't vote for that
thanks
all right
motion on the floor is ought to pass to
the amendment uh mr clerk would you
please call the roll
starting with representative seaworth
yeah i'm sorry we're voting on the
amendment
if i misspoke don't anyone get all
representative sullivan you called point
of order and then i heard something else
over there yeah i i believe the
the method that we usually follow is to
vote on the amendment itself and then
um a motion to be made ought to pass or
something like that but basically the
amendment is approved first or not
um and then we either go forward with
the bill as it originally was structured
or as it was amended
correct that's what i meant but i didn't
say it
you all knew what i meant anyway you're
right julie noted it was amandaville you
have a question
no just i wanted to apologize and and
thank you for all the kind words about
my my uh newness to the committee i
probably misspoke at the beginning and
how i introduced this so i obviously i
would like to see the amendment
passed
raised as a
to be added instead of an otp
member is a member on the floor um
you are in favor of the amendment say
aye opposed say nay mr clark please call
the roll
seaworth
no
avaloni
callum
mackie myself no
love
gordon now
turcotte nope
throat
no
boyd
in there
cahill yes
lisa vestro yes
schmidt
yes
doomy
bouchard
edgerton yes
mandeville yes
vote is is defeated 11 to
yeah bill is out for a further amendment
mr chairman i move itl
sir a second
i'd like to speak to your motion
thank you mr chairman i think this
bill has been
discussed quite a bit
mandates on businesses and this in
climate is just not in the cards
thank you mr chairman
thank you any other comments
i hope in future years someone brings
maybe something that we can wrap our
arms around because we do want people to
vote
sitting down the motion on the floor is
an experienced legislative please call
the role
seaworth
yes
papalani
callum
mackey yes
love
yes
gordon yes
boyd yes
huff
sullivan
uh pimentel
no
cahill
yes
istro
yes schmidt
no
toomey no
bouchard
adjutant
thirteen to
oh i'm sorry imma tighten
yes i knew they come out right
seven yes fourteen seven
so um representative toomey uh
representative cahill could you turn
is that all right now okay
um
what's your
is there going to be a consent agenda or
regularly
that's fine i just said it didn't have
to be i just did good all right and uh
please let me know who will be writing
the blurb for the minority
that's not solvent
yeah just uh usually what happens is the
blur will be written um by uh the
majority vote and the minority vote um
which you know
you haven't seen a house calendar yet
requiring prevailing wage
on state funded public works project
uh you can recognize
representative warden for a motion
i move and expedient to legislate
is there a second second second by
abalani
you may speak to your motion thank you
mr chairman i think the prevailing wage
thing is just going to lead to higher
prices we're already suffering through
higher prices and supply chains
shortages and uh it puts a further
hindrance on
the movement of
capital and labor
and
only only would lead to higher taxes on
new hampshire residents so
it's inappropriate for us to
pass this legislation thank you
thank you anyone else like to speak on
this
the uh
um
one of the issues i had was when
when gary abbott spoke in the hard time
how how hard it take how
long it takes and how hard it is to get
actually a prevailing wage established
so few jobs you have to direct
the government sends out a request for
information the people have to send it
back and there's so few projects they
don't send the information back and the
wages can be it could be one project in
cowas county which would have a
on one project others say that the jail
they built for instance and that would
you know
create that prevailing wage
in that county
which could be
not indicative of what's going on there
sullivan
i just want to say i'm going to be
supporting this because frankly i
support higher wages for workers and
that's what this would accomplish i
recognize that there's some problems
with it but just the same
higher wages for workers is is good for
uh thank you mr chairman one of the
concerns i have is even from the
standpoint of a prevailing wage bill the
comments from
gary abbott
pointed out that there are a number of
ways that
prevailing wages are calculated this
bill goes back to a pre-1985
language
that
at least the testimony
told us is probably not appropriate to
whatever the feeling on prevailing wage
bills in general i think
this bill language was not properly
considered
seeing no additional uh
uh comments thank you for you guys i
guess you got the message
um seeing no further
um
the motion on the floor is
uh inexplicable to legislate mr clerk
would you please call the roll
seaworth yes
avalani
callum
mackie yes
love
yes
ordon
turcotte yes
pro yes
boyd
of
yes
sullivan
no
susie
cahill
no issa vestro no
schmidt
no toomey
bouchard
adjacent
manaval
infantine
yes
well
the minority report
will be done
to be determined
okay
next on the my list is uh cacr14
[Music]
i like to
call on representative
turcotte for a motion we'll let the
cacr14
thank you mr chairman i move
cicacr14
in expedient legislate all right second
on the motion
give us a second here um
the cacr was a
constitutional
amendment that would provide workers
having a right to join a union
i'm unaware of
any law rsa regulation or anything in
our state that currently prevents an
individual from joining a union
so
that's the reason for an expedient to
legislate
i am in support of this amendment
to the new hampshire constitution
because i feel it will ensure
forever
the collective rights that are necessary
to protect
our individual rights
the right to form a collective union
which will facilitate and enhance
the ability
of their members to exercise
core civil liberties such as
the rights of association speech
and petition
this amendment
will protect the rights of individuals
forever
to come together over issues of mutual
interest
to protect the right to communicate
forever
the workers the co-workers about
workplace concerns that come from the
statutory right to join a union and
bargain collectively
as well as defending the rights of their
members forever
including by lobbying the government to
defend the interests
of the overall membership
and by going to court to protect the
rights of individual
members in closing
this amendment will end
all the anti-union crusades in new
hampshire forever
thank you mr chairman
of seaworth
thank you mr chairman i am very
concerned about the language of this
bill it's awfully vague
um about a right to join the union now
i've heard this over my many years on
the committee
people have testified that
people have a constitutional right to be
a member of the union
and i have to agree it's protected by
freedom of association freedom of
assembly
but what does this language mean it
doesn't say you have a right to be
represented in the workplace by a union
it merely guarantees membership
does that guarantee me membership if i
decide i want a screen actors guild card
can i say
constitutional right got to give it to
me or
does the union get some say in it
and and i think even during the
testimony
the sponsor
at some point talked about all the great
things this would do and in in other
sentences he described how this wouldn't
change certain things
i have a really hard time
uh with an amendment that
i just really don't understand what it's
trying to accomplish and so for that
mr chairman
my position on this will be negative
um from the viewpoint of
the constitution
as it was written
both federal and state
was amended to be le to be amended at um
not just any whim but on a serious
and well-considered situation
and so i have a problem with anything
where it says well we can mend it
when we like
but on the other hand
i'm going to specify in my amendment
that it's forever and unamendable
so i'll be voting no
seeing no other hands we have a motion
on the floor of inexperienced legislate
on cacr
14.
mr clerk please call the roll
seaworth
yes
avalonie
yes turcotte yes
yes boyd yes
yes
sullivan no
susie
pimentel
cahill yes
schmidt no
toomey
richard
no
infantine
yes
is 12 to 8
italy
i'm sorry missing yep um twelve two
one two three four five six should be
twelve to nine twelve to nine here's
i had not planned to do this today but
since the because of what happened at
um
the last hearing having been itl
kind of makes cacr 28 moot
because you can't have one without the
other
mr chairman you need a motion
yes have i caused some confusion i hear
mr chairman i move itl
second
okay
um
thank you mr chairman um the sponsor of
the trailer bill has asked for itl which
would make this
sorry i'm looking through my beard would
you're saying none mr clerk the emotion
on the floor is in explain to the
legislate on cacr28 please call the roll
seaworth yes
avaloni
callum
yes
mackey yes
love
warden yes turcotte yes
yes
boyd
puff yes
sullivan yes
susie
pimentel
cahill yes lisa vestro yes schmidt
no
saying none thank you
now i'm going to move to
um
stout this is the sister legislation
salami commission relative to minimum
wage and i repres i call on
representative abalani
is there a second
warden and please hold for go and get
you're uh recognized to speak to your
motion
thank you mr chairman um the prime
sponsor has asked us to itl the bill
noting that there are several issues
with it thank you
thank you they would like to speak
seeing none please call the roll
seaworth
yes
avalani
callum
mackie yes love
yes
warden yes turquoise yes prout yes
boyd
huff yes
sullivan
yes
susie
pimentel
mandeville yes
evantown
yes
21-0
mr chairman i move consent
the uh chairman needs to take a
five-minute break
uh when we come back we'll be looking at
house bill
1385 protecting the use of credit
history and employment decisions please
make sure that everyone has a cahill
amendment
that's a
it's actually the read amendment
um
representative cahill
did you pass around copies of your
amendment
yes
uh folks um
i am waiting for a phone call
from uh aaron goulet so if i have to
interrupt again in the middle of
something um and you're talking i'll let
brian deal with it before the executive
session so
i just it's something that
representative madigan asked me to ask
for i'm trying to get a resolution to it
so
house bill 1385 i recognize
thank you mr chair i'd like to move
which really
basically just
thank you do we have a second
thank you second by mandeville
you're recognized to speak for your
motion thank you again mr chair uh the
language that's added to the
with this amendment
covers a contractor
uh employed this was aimed at helping uh
the next terror which has contracted
providing security uh which was not
covered in the uh language from congress
so this this adds to that
uh mr berkey had uh not heard back from
his lawyers yet
but again the the idea here is that when
you're applying for a job
you're not applying for a loan you're
applying for a job so that you can
provide do the job earn the money
pay whatever current debts you have pay
any old debts you have
and just go about your business
so the the idea here is banning the uh
credit history unless it's absolutely
needed that's the idea to allow people
to apply for a job be considerate for a
job
and not have to just have this screening
question take them out
and it's also relates to people's
privacy which we value here in new
hampshire so i ask you to support this
amendment
i respect the fact that you brought
this bill a bill has come in front of us
pretty much every other year for the
last 10 or 12 years
um
it is
my opinion and the opinion that has been
shared by many people here in this in
this committee
that by the time you take out all the
people
that
are
excluded
there's very few people that are
included and we
someone probably wouldn't
request
uh the person's the prospective
employee's
permission to request a credit check
um
i just don't see it it's worth their
their their costs associated with it
however someone who's responsible for
closing up a jewelry store at night or
dealing with uh credit card payments or
dealing with anything to do with
finances would be so i i don't know
you know as i was
talking to representative seaworth at
lunch
while we try to make everything perfect
legislation is not perfect and it can't
hit everything for every situation that
could ever happen
and while not passing this may result in
one person not you know passing or
getting a job and that's that's bad i'm
sorry that that occurs
um not allowing a a business to do
something that they feel is important uh
can't agree with so while i appreciate
the attempts
and the amendment um
unfortunately i can't support it um
representative sullivan and
i guess i would just like to remind all
of us that were voting on the amendment
and i believe the amendment makes an
improvement that um mr berkey
specifically asked for
and however you feel about the
underlying bill um i think the amendment
uh takes care of a problem and uh i
think it's it would be good for the
record to show that we attended to the
issues that were brought before us thank
you
cahill
thank you mr chair i would just like to
address i understand your concern
but a person who owes money doesn't
necessarily mean the person who will
steal money
so we're sort of a i think there's a
fourth amendment here so you're you're
presuming that someone who's behind on
their bills right reach into the drawer
and
take something out or do something like
having bad credit is not a criminal
offense
thank you mr chairman um
regarding this is we're first voting on
the amendment and
i do have some discomfort uh with the
language i do
understand in some ways it's better
um it also changes the line on 19 about
the bona fide purpose and add some
restrictive language
and as you were saying mr chairman
there's a lot of exceptions to this and
and the original language sort of
granted those of exceptions in one way
and this one reigns it in a lot
in a way that i'm not sure i fully
understand so i for one cannot support
i have to respond
representative cahill i'm not presuming
anything
um i don't perform background checks on
my employees that's just my choice
um
it's up to the employer
so i'm not making any dispersion that
someone has a bad credit
and that they would be uh apt to steal
seeing none uh oh yes go ahead yeah i
just want to clarify that i i didn't
suggest that you yourself were doing but
the employer may perceive that this
person is unreliable and
could could uh embezzle or whatever
yeah um
motion on the floor is the amendment uh
huh
h
no
yes on house bill
1385.
mr
clerk would you please call the roll
seaworth
no
avalani
macky no
love no
borden
sullivan yes
susie
pimentel
cahill
yes piece of estro yes
schmidt yes to me yes
bouchard
edgerton yes minival yes
infantine no
11 to 10.
defeated
the motions defeated the bill is open to
further uh
motions
over seaworth
i'd like to make a motion inexpedient to
legislate
second babyloni
you may speak to your motion thank you
mr chairman uh you've covered a lot of
it
like the chairman i've seen this bill a
number of times
and quite honestly i'm sympathetic i
in a lot of cases employers
are not well served by considering the
credit history of their employees
but sometimes they are
and when this bill comes in inevitably
the process starts of lobbyists coming
forward trying to make sure that
this
in in this public hearing i heard one
new exception that i hadn't thought of
and it wasn't it wasn't a represented
constituency i have to imagine for
everyone we find there there's probably
another one that we haven't thought of
um so i i echo the chairman's concerns
about this bill
we can't
make the right decision for every single
employee in the state and
um
you mike what
representative cahill would you like to
speak
just to miss the communication here i i
seeing there's no other comments uh mr
uh seaworth
yes
avalani
callum yeah mackie yes love yes
orton yes
turcotte yes
yes
boyd yes
tough yes sullivan no
susie
yes
schmidt yes
bouchard
adjutant
mandeville
no no
yes sorry yes
that's why i raised my eyes i knew you
were going to do it later
representative sullivan
ready for 1386
uh
minority
next bill um
is uh uh house bill 1386 study committee
the effects of heat and is uh i'll call
representative sullivan for um
motion
thank you mr chairman i would like to
move um
h
have a second
second by robert kale
um
1386 1386
amendment by representative sullivan
if you're looking through your list the
oh yeah i was going to
do yours in itl that one yes
yeah okay okay
may i speak to my amendment
you sure can
yes i just want to make sure you got
yeah i got it yeah yes go ahead
representative sullivan okay um
basically this uh amendment um my my
name's on on this amendment as a
courtesy to uh two prime sponsors one of
them is uh
um
representative reed um
who's the prime sponsor for 1386 the
other is representative perez who is the
prime sponsor for 1304 which was on our
slate to be uh heard today
and i understand that
rep perez was
had a medical emergency and was was
unable to make it but uh regardless both
reps um agreed to this and the reason
for the amendment is simply that we
ended up with two bills that we were
incredibly similar
and it didn't make sense to
have them in competition with each other
made better sense to uh
simply combine them
because one of them dealt with heat
heat in the workplace
referencing mostly interior spaces the
other one dealt with heat and cold
referencing primarily outdoor spaces
so
this amendment combines both of them to
the satisfaction of both prime sponsors
i think it just cleans things up for the
committee and makes it uh
clearer for us to move forward on the
issue that was put before us so i ask
for your support simply because
it
clerk and call the roll
uh seaworth
yes
avalani
callum
mackie yes love yes
orton
turcotte yes
yes
boyd
off
yes
sullivan
susie yes
rudy oh i'm sorry up to mattel yeah
gay hill yes
you silvestro yes
schmidt yes
toomey
bouchard
hatchitin yes
mandeville
infantine yes
i move out to
you're recognized to speak to your
motion
i i do believe that there are problems
in the workplace with uh with with
temperatures osha recently uh came up
cold temperatures i believe it was no no
it was it was heat in the workplace and
essentially they've got a new tool for
employers to use to assist their
employees and i think
the way this uh amended bill is put
together
for studying these things to figure out
what types of guidance we can give to
employers to help keep their workers
safe
and
i'm all about worker safety and that's
what this bill does so i ask for your
support for ought to pass his amendment
thank you mr chairman i am going to vote
against this motion
um
one issue i have
we had to postpone this vote because we
had difficulty
getting the people here to work on it
we have a shortage of people we have a
shortage of facilities there are a lot
of concerns about people meeting and i
think we have to be very cautious about
how much we we set aside to study um in
the upcoming months given all those
conditions
i'm told that as much trouble as we have
the senate is even more hard on this and
they're not going to entertain
um a lot of studies being passed
if you're if my namesake from across the
aisle thinks back to the previous
session i gave a similar comment to a
study bill that he proposed and i ended
up supporting that on the house floor
um and it passed and and has been
enacted i think there are some
differences here and for the future i i
the the bill to study the osha
requirements for state workers
had been a long time getting ready
it had been submitted as a previous bill
before that there was an ad
advocacy group that had been working
hard on it
and i think in putting forth that study
the sponsors knew very well
what they were trying to accomplish
where they would get the information and
and what that information would be doing
once passed
we as legislators are not well most of
us are not scientists or or data
analysts
we legislate we get involved in that
there ought to be a law
point in the process
and
i fully sympathize with the sponsor she
made the comment that she's done as much
work as she could she's looking for help
i would suggest
that there's maybe a little bit further
to go between it seems like there's a
problem let's let's look at all the
stuff out there
and the point where we kind of see
a problem the information that'll feed
into the law so i suggest that
especially
in this time but probably in general too
this is a concept that
probably needs to be worked a little
more
before it belongs in a legislative study
committee
we agreed to uh support the amendment
um because we wanted to at least you
have that ability
to move forward if you choose to on the
floor
um we have a couple problems and i'd
like to just reiterate what the vice
chairman said
um you know how hard it is to find a
senator they're not willing to play
right now
the speaker doesn't want a lot of
study committees because
certain individuals don't want to even
come to the state house
so this kind of defeats the purpose of
they don't want to come to the state
house but yet we want to have study
committees to come to the state house
and study
i went online over the weekend and
looked under osha and a few other things
and there are volumes on
heat
prevention all these things that are
that are there
so i'm not going to support this but
what i will
do is as chairman of the other study
committee
you can add this to that
since we already have a senator which
we're probably not going to get another
that that's what a
compromise i can make that it will be
you know in those discussions we can
bring that up
so i will be uh i won't be supporting it
but um
at least your amendment was uh well
appreciated
english and the floors ought to pass
with amendment if you're in favor you
vote yes if you're opposed no mr clerk
seaworth
no
avaloni
sullivan yes susie
and mattel
cahill
no
lisa vestro
yes
schmidt no
toomey
bouchard
henchmen
infantine
no
i recognize representative seaworth
i uh
move
i
believe i've already said plenty so i'll
pass on that thank you
we can just wait a few minutes here
who's the second
the most has been made second
the motion maker has uh stated their
piece uh
uh mr chairman thank you could i just
understand if what you said uh
previously was that your concept was
that this the subject matter that's
contained within this
bill could be subject matter for an
existing study committee
that i would be willing to add it to
that in that discussion
thank you that was correct
a mission to deal with
utilizing making municipalities adhere
i i think it's
germain enough that um if the
committee's willing to do it
we'll see that's brian
who's in the committee with me lino
myself brian
and the senator if they're all in
agreement we can if not you know but at
least it provides that
all right seeing no others
call the roll
avalani
callum
yes
mackie yes love yes
warden
sullivan yes
susie
pimentel
cahill yes
lisa vestro
schmidt yes
toomey
richard
adjutant yes
mandeville
21-0
yes
oh evan
sorry
house bill 1304 establishes activities
so that the impact of outdoor working
conditions and heating cold this
was the um
kind of the similar bill
like a motion representative
i move in expedient to legislate
thank you and my motion was simply we
combined the two bills into one and so
this one is no longer necessary
and we'll be uh willing to uh wishing to
speak
seeing none the emotion on the floor is
in experience to legislate
and we'll call the role in a few minutes
all right if you are go ahead
uh seaworth
yes
avalani
alum
yes
mackie yes love yes
warden yes
yes proud yes boyd
huff
yes sullivan yes susie yes pimentel
cahill yes
dee salvestro yes schmidt yes toomey
bouchard
adjutant yes mandeville yes
infante yes
21-0
hospital 1156
requiring a certain public servants to
receive a copy of pre-employment
background investigation
i recognize representative
correct
i move uh 1156 inexpedient to legislate
on the floor expedia legislate paul
13 here
um why don't you just um
and then you can ask
for another one from heather it looks
okay the motion was made by
representative turcotte on house bill
it was seconded by representative
amalani
emotional it was itl representative
turcotte you recognize your motion
speaking of motion thank you mr chairman
we heard extensive testimony by two
individuals in law enforcement who
conduct these investigative background
investigations um both of them were
adamant that they thought this was not a
good idea
the other issue or the other
point that they made is out of the
hundreds that they've done
only one or two have actually ever
one was requested one ended up i think
in court and
they've only been required to turn over
something one time if i recall
um
they also mentioned the potential for
additional litigation and
it's just overall it's not a good idea
they sign off if they're
applying for employment they're
obviously signing off on something that
allows the
background
check and investigation and final point
as a couple of them said
generally
when they're denied employment they know
the reason why
so uh for those reasons i support itil
thank you anyone else i can speak
i
have to say that when i first saw this i
it didn't
strike me as being a law enforcement uh
issue so i was frankly in in favor of
providing these background checks um
good example of when a hearing makes a
difference um there are two very
impressive
individuals who uh testified um and uh
i was clearly persuaded that uh turning
over these background checks
would violate some confidentiality that
would be detrimental to the process and
possibly detrimental to people who
on the way home i was thinking to myself
that
probably not everyone who does
exceptional as those two folks were but
that being said um
i was certainly persuaded that
this
turning over these background checks
would be a bad idea so i will
this was a difficult one for me because
i like uh transparency in government
and not let someone see that at first
blush was was disconcerting
um
i know this is not just for police it's
fire and other
um police in our society right now are
under considerable scrutiny
and um
and
one of the comments was made by the the
chief so i'll just cop you know
repeat it you know we don't want a bad
apple
so they have to look at
all these background checks and
so to me it's like okay so what's the
check and balance to make sure it's just
not a personal issue
well
it's only happened a few times
if you want you can file a
a suit and that's all discoverable you
can that get the discovery
if the police think that
through that discovery process
that
they probably don't want to give up that
information about something especially
if it was
you know maybe a neighbor or a next
relationship or something
so then it can go in front of a judge
and it's called in camera where the
judge will sit there in front of the
courtroom with both attorneys and he'll
look at it
and he'll make a determination of
whether or not that that really should
be given up or not without having to you
know
uh put anyone possibly in any jeopardy
so
there are mechanisms
and that with that
uh i believe um that while
we do need to have transparency in
government this might be a place where
the transparency happens but a further
couple down the line
so i'll be supporting the motion divide
of itl
seeing none the emotion on the floor
isn't expedient to legislate
mr clerk would you please call the role
seaworth yes
pavalani
callum yes
mackie no
love yes
orton no
turcotte
yes
boyd
huff
sullivan yes
susie yes
clementel
cahill yes decelvestro yes schmidt yes
toomey
bouchard
adjutant yes manival yes
infantine
yes 19 to two
i'm i'm okay with the consent but i'll
defer to representative mackey i'm okay
with content
all right thank you
house bill 1231 relative to failure to
make payment or compensation i recognize
thank you mr chairman i move itl
reward sure
yeah he was excited
i think there's a few other people here
that need to
who made that again i understand sorry
abhilani fall seconded by a very uh
yes
governor mavalani you're
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you mr chairman um
there was some back and forth with the
department about whether
um
kerry should make payments directly
whether the department should make
payments directly
how many issues there actually are per
year
um i suggest
if this is
really an issue we should take up with
the department come back with something
better than this legislation thank you
mr chairman
i i agree we um uh
representative turcotte
seaworth and i had
some
considerable discussions about it
you know should be part of the fine
should it be a third of the fine what
should it be i know there were some
other calls made
to the department trying to figure out
how many
i thoroughly agree that if someone is in
a position where they're just egregious
and they're
continuously late paying people
that
there's a potential where a fine
should
be made
as well as then
maybe compensation to the
employee or to the
injured worker
for having to wait
we need some data as to how often it
happens
how frequent it happens are they mostly
a day
they didn't have a lot of the
information we needed and they rarely
utilize this
so we don't know whether or not this is
a problem and whether
i'm all in favor of making it much
harsher if it seems to be
continuous with certain insurance
carriers i am aware
three or four years ago there was one
and someone was brought to the carpet
and almost lost their license to
transact business in the state until
they straightened up
so the the department does seem to get
on these things
we get some better information
from the department
and we find that it is a problem
i know
the vice chairman i have discussed about
sullivan
this this bill didn't really address the
issue that uh i i think most of us
recognize is
the more serious issue which is late
payments of regular weekly
uh compensation um instead it was
looking at the length of time it took
to get a hearing done and then get the
um
the compensation approved
and
it it seemed that
hearings could get delayed by no fault
of anybody's and the penalties could
could
come come into play um
uh without it really being the fault of
anyone so um i guess i would like to see
a bill that addresses late payments of
regular compensation checks rather than
um
a slower than uh desirable um
a hearing process
so
any other comments
seeing you on the motion on the floor is
an explaining to legislate mr clerk
would you please call the role seaworth
yes
avalani
callum
mackey yes love
gordon yes turcotte yes oh yes boyd
huff
sullivan yes susie
pimentel
cahill yes yes of estro yes schmidt yes
uh bouchard
adjutant
mandeville
it doesn't matter i just thought you had
said we were going to do this
we could do more but representative
tony's two weeks left i want to be fair
to everybody um and there could be some
you know whatever so we've done more
than i expected to do so i'm ready to
determine to
close the executive session if that's
all right question for the chair
on those bills we execute today
when do you need the majority and
by 5 15.
i only need the ones on 1207 and 15 38
by monday of next week
it'll be best they're due on thursday
but i like to have my monday so we don't
crush heather
and the other ones uh sometime next week
get to me so we can have them for the
following week if we have a a session
a house session
we could i just because someone left
unless it's unless it's something you
really want i would wait till the next
it
again it could be but um
uh oh no i'm sorry 1076. yes we were
going to do that just so let me let me
just close okay
slow down here
representative adagen and i have worked
on an amendment
to house bill 1076.
okay um
you most of you didn't get it for the
last couple hours
you folks asked me in caucus not to
present it today because you needed to
review it
um and uh
that
yes
we are definitely doing it we are
definitely doing it next
thursday it'll be the first order of
business next thursday in our executive
session i might even do it quickly
between a bill
we have
um so please um if you have questions on
it i would appreciate if you look at it
email either representative or i
okay
um that being said i've kept you long
enough thank you very much uh we're
close
close the labor committee hearing
session for the day and i'll be here if
you